all right 9:00 a.m. welcome everybody to
the the house election law committee I'm
going to start off today with some
public hearings but first uh Vice
chairman B will lead us in the
pledge okay it's good to be back home
room 306 Where We
Belong right
um going to open up the public hearing
on House Bill uh 1146 relative to the
removal of Voters from the checklist uh
Representative Keith Ammon is recognized
to introduce the bill welcome to
election law representative Ammon thank
you Mr chair and good morning members of
the election law committee uh for the
record my name is Keith Ammon and I
represent Hillsboro District
42 and that includes the towns of New
Boston Mount Vernon and
lineboro and I'm here to introduce uh
House Bill
1146 that deals with the removal of a
voter from the
checklist so this bill this is a
constituent request this bill and um
we'll hear some testimony from uh the
constituent that requested the bill
after me and uh so I'll tell the story
as as I can recall it in Mount Vernon uh
there was a voter who would who
requested to be removed from the
checklist and um the Secretary of
State's office I believe uh said that
that's not possible there isn't a
statute that allows someone to do that
which is surprising to me and so that's
what this bill would do it it would
create a process for someone to request
their name to be removed from the
checklist and this would be similar to
if someone moved out of state or out of
district and there were no longer uh you
know uh validly part of the
checklist um and so the process is very
similar and you might ask why would
someone want to do this um I think it
would be personal reasons but I can
think of a few um someone might be
disaffected with politics someone might
be uh there's some religions that uh
don't allow someone to vote uh so
someone might have a a change in faith
that would require them uh to not vote
and so I I couldn't tell you the
particular reason for this uh this
constituent request um but I think there
should be a process uh that
is uh verifiable and make sure that the
checklist remains you know uh keeps its
Integrity so that we have uh solid
voting uh
roles so with that I'll I'll take any
questions
questions from the committee
representative
Lane thank you um I'm out of
practice um can they come back and sign
up again is there a process where or
once they're off they're off no they
could change their mind again and they'd
have to go through the process of of you
know reestablishing their their name on
the voter
roles further questions
um I actually have one um would you I
know that this is a constituent bill but
would you be opposed if we change
sections 1 and two basically lines 8
through 13 instead of having it be
witnessed by an election official if it
was just a notorized um because to your
point about somebody moves right now in
theory they'd have to fly back to New
Hampshire uh to go to the town to be
removed um instead of just having it
would you be objectionable to that if it
was just a notorized
document yeah what however the committee
uh sees fit um I know the person coming
after me is actually uh the the
supervisor of a checklist in Mount
Vernon so they may have some additional
input on that question uh any other
questions from the committee this might
be the fastest one we do today all right
thank you representative Ammon okay
thank you uh next up is William
Sandford
um Mr Sanford what town do you live in
when you get up
here I'm in Mount Vernon Mount ver
most people have never heard of it I
have heard of Mount Vernon and not just
uh and not just the
um George
Washington spelled spelled
differently good to go all right I'm one
of the supervisors of the checklist we
have three and I've been doing this for
about eight years now I just signed up
to be on the ballot for the next term uh
this bill came because a constituent a
voter came to me and wanted to be
removed from the checklist so I started
to do it and I realized there's no way
to do this on Election net so I called
Bud Fitch and he said that's right you
have no power to take somebody off the
checklist unless number one they die or
number two they have moved out of the
jurisdiction and that's very easy to do
now in answer to your question uh if
somebody leaves the checklist once to be
removed from the checklist and then they
want to come back to the checklist it's
very easy to do all they have to do is
re-register for us to remove someone is
it takes two seconds to do that on the
election net for us to re-register them
it takes three seconds to do that so
there's no time involved in
this
um as far as as far as the voter is
concerned this is the one person in
eight years that has requested to to be
removed from the checklist so it's not a
common practice but it should be
legal are you willing to take questions
from the committee sure are there
questions from the committee
representative wood Yeah you mentioned
uh legal ways to take your name off the
checklist are the those the only two yes
so the ask for a follow up there I'm
sorry it's all right you go ahead so you
were saying the uh if the death death
certificate so that Trigg is the removal
well we get we get news of a person who
has passed from the vital records
Network in New Hampshire so it will call
it will show up on our election net
reminder screen I don't know if you're
familiar with election net okay it shows
up on the reminder screen so we um take
a look at that we remove the voter from
the checklist so they're gone forever as
far as somebody moving out of the CH out
of the
jurisdiction um if they have registered
in another town or another state we will
also know about that so we can remove
them but those are the only two ways
right now you thank you for saving
another followup thank
you represent B yeah also you to another
state you get a notice uh is that always
true because for example my
granddaughter had moved working in in
Chicago some years ago and she had a
Illinois driver's license everything and
was Voting in Chicago and in order to be
removed town clerk says she needs to
come to show her ID which she couldn't
because she was you know so you said you
get notice but you only get notice if
the J new jurisdiction sends you notice
there are 28 states that use the
election net system and if she was not
in one of those States then we wouldn't
know about it but if she hasn't voted in
the last four years or in the last four
elections but that we would have a purge
right yeah okay thank
you further questions representative wey
uh just for uh hypothetical so to help
me understand removing people from the
checklist suppose you had
someone uh in in the town or Community
who uh noticed that someone was uh no
longer living in their uh residents but
had um not
registered or had not uh filed anything
saying they should be removed from the
checklist um is there any mechanism to
deal with that sort of issue where if
they haven't you know if they voted
within the last couple of years but but
they have since moved out but provided
no notification and hadn't yet been
registered on the you know uh electronic
list yeah to to uh be able to notify you
directly well periodically during the
year we form a 30-day list where we put
people on the list that we think have
moved out of town or even out of state a
neighbor could tell us hey so and so
sold his house and moved out of town so
we put that person on a 30-day list and
we send them a letter if you don't
respond within 30 days you'll be removed
from the
checklist but that's the only way we can
do something like
that further questions followup yeses
that that is that codified within the
RSA or is is that a good just a good so
it is okay right and we do that
periodically during the year maybe twice
a year in our small town maybe twice a
year yeah thank you further questions
representative
Bay so um if some you said uh somebody
might have said that uh a neighbor had
moved and and so forth um is there no
other a formal process because if if uh
for example if a person is not very
friendly to their neighbors and no one
had told you so that that person will be
forever in the checklist in
theory again we'd have to send them a
30-day may I follow up it's fine Mr
chair yes um so there there's no process
of
um let's say uh the realtor will so the
house uh and then there there will be a
notification no okay the problem with
somebody saying so and so sold their
house at times they sold their house but
they move within the town so we can't
remove them from the checklist we can
change their address but we can't remove
them thank you thank you Mr chair person
of course further questions from the
committee saying none thank you so much
no um last up to speak is Dan Healey
from the New Hampshire uh clerks in you
know what you know who yeah you know who
you're from I'll and I'll learn to speak
English
today hi uh Dan Hy uh NAA city clerk uh
president of the New Hampshire Clerk's
Association uh so we oppose um HB
1146 uh the law already provides a few
ways to remove a voter from the
checklist and we our concerns with this
bill um allowing someone to come in and
have their name removed uh whenever
they'd like poses a problem so for this
past presidential primary uh party
changes closed October 6th so someone
that didn't switch their party could
come in remove themsel from the voter
checklist so then re-register on
Election Day as the party that they um
then wanted uh also we have residents
that come in that don't like that um the
voter checklist is public and they don't
want their name on it so they come in
they ask to be removed but they intend
to still vote in the future so they
would be removing themselves to
re-register and so we get the intent of
the bill
but overall with the different
scenarios um I think a person could come
in they could remove themselves to then
be added
later uh just for these these various
reasons uh that's why we oppose this
bill i' be open to any questions
questions from the
committee okay uh so if we fix the uh
party switch Clause you'd be good to
go um so what would that entail it would
be a provision in the bill that said you
know you cannot use this for the purpose
of changing your party after the
deadline because I just I think it would
be hard to track on Election Day uh a
lot of the um the supervisors of the
checklist or the registrars depending on
how big the um the municipality is they
don't have access to see if someone's
registered prior so I think someone came
in they registered prior and then they
register again on election day there's
not a lot of ways to go back and check
that until we're entering it the days
following so I think it it kind of
complicates
things okay I'm going oh I
representative where
you uh well I I I do but we let we're
supposed to let other reps to ask before
you just start doing the follow-ups all
right um so there was recently a ruling
by the First Circuit Court of Appeals uh
that the under the national voter
registration Act of 1993 Main's voter
roles had to be public record does that
impact your position on whether or not
voter voter checklists have to be uh
made public so our voter checklist right
now is public so it's um so I'm I'm the
clerk out of NASA if you walked into the
NASA City Hall our voter uh checklist is
sitting on the uh desk in the lobby of
of the city clerk's office so anyone can
come in and and look at that information
and I did have a situation a few years
ago where um when I was working in a
different municipality a voter came in
and they asked for their name to be
removed but they informed me that they
are still interested in voting at every
election they want their name to be
removed and then to re-register every
time just because they didn't want uh
someone to be able to come in and look
up their information so I do we have
those concerns that it could be used in
that way
further
questions representative HR um wouldn't
that be a confidential voter or is that
a different so a a confidential voter um
if they have a your court order
protective order um where their identity
needs to be hidden that's a separate um
issue this this person uh did not have
that they were just looking they didn't
want maybe the phone calls or the mail
or maybe their neighbor to see what
party they're registered as they just
wanted to be removed entirely from the
list further questions representative
Lane thank you um can you just remind us
again what information is on the voter
checklist so on the voter checklist is
their uh unique voter ID that's
generated when we enter the voter into
our election portal uh it's their name
um their domicile
address their party
affiliation further
questions so this they're sending in an
affidavit could we have a checkbox on
the affidavit that says that they do not
intend to vote in the next election
would that ass suade your concern since
an affidavit is a sworn statement
um that would yeah that would help um I
just I see it being used used not for
the way that it was intended I get the
intention of it of the bill and um we
you know we agree with the intention but
we looking at it we think that it could
be used for you know other ways around
say the party affiliation thing or to
get someone's name off the list and then
just go back
on okay uh further questions seeing none
thank you so much uh last up is the a
late entry the great secretary skate
David scanley
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State um I just want to provide a
little information on this bill um I
understand the reason why somebody might
submit it because we get plenty of calls
in our office from voters who would like
to have their name removed from the list
for various reasons probably the most
common one is the amount of mail uh that
they get during campaign season but uh
voters get particularly a aggravated
when the number of phone calls uh and
personal contacts go way up um we try to
explain to the voters when they call
that in the in the process of collecting
the voter registration information when
they fill out the form we are not taking
their phone number uh or their email
address that whoever is contacting them
has gotten that data from some other uh
location um there is a a
a a basic premise to elections and that
is uh in addition to you know voters
having the right to vote and to do so
conveniently and easily there is also a
right for members of a community to know
who is particip ipating in the election
process and that's why checklists are
important and that's why there's a voter
history that is uh tagged along with
that so that uh anybody who's interested
can make sure that the voters that are
participating are actually qualified uh
to vote in an
election the um couple of concerns that
I have with the bill are uh
one if you were uh as a matter of policy
we're going to let people be removed
from the checklist there's no direction
in here about the frequency at which
that could happen I mean technically you
could have people showing up and
registering at the polls on the day of
the
election and then having their name
removed from the N list the next day if
not
sooner and you know that causes problems
in making sure I mean if if if there was
concern about whether that individual
was qualified to vote being able to
track them uh and and just you know
verify their their status as a
voter um I'm looking at the bill itself
on page
one lines 11 through 13 Roman numeral
number two where it says that a voter
shall present a valid photo
identification to the official and this
is to have their name removed from the
list the election official offal shall
examine the photo
identification and confirm that the name
domicile address and date of birth match
the information provided on the
affidavit there are many forms of
acceptable ID that can be presented
photo ID that does not have that
information on it it could be the name
of a of a person who um got married and
their name changed so that information
might not be accurate there are many
photo IDs that do not have birth dates
on them uh and and even a driver's
license may not have an accurate
domicile address so I I think that uh
you know that that provision in the
statute or in the proposed
legislation uh is
[Music]
problematic I think I'll stop there Mr
chairman and and just answer any
questions the committee might have
excellent questions from the
committee represent weing uh thank you
secretary scandin would so if if the
identification aligned with uh other
areas of the RSA that um for
registration would you be amendable to
that I I think that if I think that if
the committee were going to go along
with this that if you matched up the the
comparison of the information you just
use similar language to other sections
of the statute like a registration form
thank you representative
qua thank you Mr chairman uh the idea
was mentioned just a couple of minutes
ago about someone going through this
process and filling out an affidavit
that they I think it was said wouldn't
vote in the next election could could
someone actually alienate their right to
vote in that fashion so they couldn't
change their mind before the next
election I don't believe they could I
think that would be a violation of
constitutional rights thank
you further questions all right seeing
none thank you secretary scalan uh
there's no other oh you know what I
don't have my computer up yet um there's
no other speakers signed up to speak and
if the committee will indulge me I
should have had my computer up for this
uh I'll read the uh sign in um I tell
you what we'll actually stand in recess
till 9:30 which when the next one starts
and I'll get my uh things up it's all
right we'll we'll wait till 9:30 all
right so we in recess till
9:30
for
s
watch
not
much
prop
say
so
not
here
okay okay it's uh 9:30 going to
reconvene the uh public hearings on the
house election law committee going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
1147 relative to the permissible
contributions by business organizations
and labor unions going to recognize uh
representative Lane purely for the
purpose of introduction of the
bill uh thank you Mr chair uh I'm Connie
Lane I represent uh marac district 16 in
conquered ward two uh I am introducing
this bill as a professional courtesy to
representative uh Reed who is a
professional uh I'm
sorry who is in another committee
meeting and can't be present
here you're and I'm not going to be able
to answer any questions I'm sorry
question comments okay uh so what we're
going to do here representative Reed did
let me know um she has another bill um
being introduced literally at the exact
same time by the way thank you
representative Lane um for doing that um
so what we're going to do is we're we're
going to start the public testimony the
um and when representative re gets here
um if we're still in the middle of
public testimony I will probably try to
pause the public testimony allow her to
kind of do the formal introduction but
what I don't want is the committee to
fall behind today um so we're going to
be a little ad hoc on that um but I want
to respect everybody's time so first up
to speak uh we'll do um Olivia
zinc
uh good morning members of the committee
my for the record my name is Olivia zinc
I'm a voter in Franklin and the
executive director of open democracy
just wanted to give some background um
this we have um prohibition of campaign
spending in our laws and in
1999 um uh stretch Kennedy took this to
court against Bill Gardner and uh the
court basically said that corporations
were allowed owed to make campaign
contributions um but they needed to do
it through a segregated fund the court
outlined what the legislator needed to
do to fix this and this is what that is
so this is just making our law our
campaign law compliant with what the
court asked us to do years ago um so
that's all this is um it should be a
simple thing um and if anybody wants the
court case Kennedy versus Gardener um
I'm happy to bring it or email it um I
didn't print it out this morning
apologies um with that I can take some
questions if anyone has any Kennedy
versus Gardner I would have loved to
seeing that one that two names which
shall live in infamy representative Wei
so so that took place in 1999 you said
correct I was at high schooler in 1999 I
won't say where I was um thank you very
much further questions from the
committee okay seeing none uh next up
will be Katherine
langel good morning uh for the record my
name is Katherine LEL and I'm a year old
voter from conquered I'm a student at St
anom College serving as open democracy
actions public policy fellow um open
democracy action is a nonpartisan
nonprofit uh that focuses on advocating
for campaign Finance reform uh and and
voter rights so this bill came to our
attention um after examining the bill I
urge the committee to vote a to pass um
the language used would standardize
actions taken by labor unions and
business organizations to participate in
government
um the ability for groups to express
their support is pivotal to our
democracy um and lines 13 through 15 of
the proposed Bill read quote provided
the committee's expenditures and
contributions are made through a
separate segregated fund consisting only
of voluntary
contributions um solicited from
individuals who are employees officers
Etc um this language would ensure that
the money allocated to support any
political Pursuit would come directly
from within the union or the group
itself eliminating the potential for
private gain um and it would like I said
essentially standardize this process um
which could be very helpful in
uh helping with uh sorry trying to word
this it's
[Music]
morning uh standardizing it and helping
with election uh integrity and campaign
Integrity um yeah my I'm so proud to say
that my dad was the vice president of
the conquered firefighters 1045 local
1045 so I asked him about this bill um
to gain some context because I'm a
college student I did not know very much
about kind of how this works um and he
was able to provide uh some context and
let me know that this is a this process
is a lot of what people already do
standardizing it would just uh secure
that Integrity so I'm happy to take
questions okay questions from the
committee representative
Lane um thank you uh my understanding is
that this puts corporations and unions
on a level footing is that correct am I
understanding that correct when you talk
about the process and sure okay
um that wasn't my understanding my
understanding was
that that's my
boss um so it would yes uh both
processes would be standardized so yeah
further questions from the committee
okay hearing none um thank you um we
don't have anyone else sign up to speak
I will say I forgot to announce on 11:46
we had 51 signed up in support three
opposed uh with that this committee this
bill will be recessed until but
basically what we're going to do is kind
of like rolling five minute recesses so
you can kind of go where you want to go
it's enough time to use the bathroom and
come back um so we're going to reset
until 9:40 and if representative Reed's
not here I'm going to gavl in and gavel
out till 9:45 and then at 9:45 I'll
gavel in and gavel out till 950 and
we'll just keep going like that until
representative re can come here um so
that's the game plan so with that I will
see you guys at 9:40 to start the five
minute rolling gavels thank
you
the
testimony newly three is the the
thing
okay it's 9:40 the sponsor is not here
yet so I'm going to gavel Us in and I'm
going to recess until 9:45 thank
you
okay it's 9:45 so I'm going to reopen
the public hearing and then I'm going to
immediately recess it till 9:50 see you
guys in 5
minutes
okay it's 9:50 we are going to resume
the public hearing on 11:47
representative Reed for your situational
awareness your bill has been introduced
two people have testified in favor of it
uh and we are eagerly awaiting for your
real introduction now thank you so much
Mr chair and thank you to the entire
committee for your patience as you are
aware I had uh a 9:30 a.m. bill in my
own uh committee that I needed to
introduce so I I apologize um I will be
brief I guess you've all waited so long
already um so this bill adds a few
necessary protections for our election
workers as well as uh some extra
protections for our process the
Integrity of um the ballot and machine
process um the reason this is necessary
is that I'm going to I'm going to pause
you we're on
11:47 this
afternoon we'll see
you
for for the for the need a hell of an
amendment for that need a hell of
amendment all right we'll try this again
all right repres TR 11:47 relative to
the permissible campaign contribut by
business organization unions thank you
so much Mr chair um I do have to
introduce four of my own bills today so
um one down and apparently three more to
go okay so uh thank you this bill simply
seeks to treat Corporation corporate
political donations the same as we
already treat labor union donations the
history of this is that back in the the
teens 19 teens around 1917 Teddy
Roosevelt um famously railed against
political corruption and um under that
Administration direct um contributions
from corporations became illegal across
the country still is illegal to this day
uh for federal elections from
corporations to political campaigns at
that time very many states New Hampshire
included also made direct um or made any
donations from corporations to uh
political campaigns illegal after that
came the rise of labor unions and at
that time our laws which are still the
laws on the books today said that labor
unions can donate but it has to be from
a segregated fund it can't be from the
the general fund which is funded by dues
it has to be from separate political
what we call today a Pac political fund
that is specifically donated to for
political purposes um and so what we had
was a complete ban on corporate
donations and a kind of
regulation on uh on labor union
donations and in the 90s so nearly a
hundred years after the original
complete ban on corporations um the
Supreme Court of the state struck down
the corporate ban is overly Broad and
they specifically in their casee as you
may have already heard um referenced the
fact that the regulation on labor unions
allowed donations as long as it was from
a dedicated fund and therefore um the
corporate language should be the same
and they recommended that we do exactly
that in our
legislation and we never did it simply
was struck down and we never went back
and did what the Supreme Court said
which was to have the same language
impact corporations and labor unions
equally and that is what this bill does
so it simply says the the labor unions
the language that already exists I
simply add or business so in that first
paragraph So the existing words are by
any L labor union or group of labor
unions and then it says um because this
is under the prohibition and then I say
or by any business organization or any
officer acting in the business so we're
just we're bringing it under the same
language and then these second paragraph
says allows for that political action
committee for both labor unions and
explicitly for both L labor unions and
businesses and with that I'm happy to
take questions questions from the
committee representative weie wrong
Bill hi thank you for your
testimony
um I understand that that uh there are
also single single member llc's that
would be equivalent to sole
proprietorships but there is a
distinction within the Secretary of
State's office I think for company
registrations and the like would you be
amendable
to uh amending that uh last line on
eight and N to include single member
llc's if that's the the direction this
committee wanted to go in I would
support that I just think the major
thing is that we do not treat unions and
businesses differently when it comes to
their politic iCal
donations thank you representative
Hamlet thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
um how does this relate to the citizens
united decision didn't is this more
restrictive so this only has to do with
direct contributions to political
campaigns the citizens united decision
has to do with independent expenditures
so that these are two completely
separate um issues so just to be clear
for the entire Committee in case there's
any confusion because obviously all
these things can get confusing um so a
direct contribution is where a business
which is what I seek to address or a
labor union or whoever directly gives
money to a campaign Ellen for New
Hampshire for example um an independent
expenditure is and according to Citizens
United there has to be no cooperation
between the two groups is where I might
on my own buy ads for Joan Hamlet right
but you're not supposed to cooperate
with me on that whatsoever and what
citizens united said is that that
independent expenditure as long as
there's no cooperation is unregulated
and and unlimited but this is only has
to do with direct
contributions okay thank you further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you representative see we did it
we did it we did it I apologize and
thank you so much for your patience and
also patience with me being confused no
worries um okay uh that is the last of
people signed up to speak in person
actually let me give you the card uh
this is
1760 and she really was confused
1140 well this is 11:47 uh okay um sign
up online was 14 in support one oppose
Zer neutral with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 11:47
we'll be recessed till 10: a.m. for the
purpose of introduction of House Bill
1074 did you say AOS uh it was oh you 14
to1 all right see you guys in 3
minutes
okay 10: a.m. welcome back everybody
going to reopen the public hearing of
the house election law committee going
to recognize representative McGee for
the purpose introduction of House Bill
uh 1074 relative to campaign
contributions by limited liability
companies representative McGee welcome
to election law uh thank you so much
chairman Barry and members of election
law committee thank you for having me
here today um to introduce hb1 uh
1074 relative to campaign contributions
by limited liability companies or
llc's I'm representative cat McGee from
Hillsboro 35 which is Hollis um in the
last several Cycles we have had some
form of this bill and it is
affectionately known as the LLC loophole
bill so you may have heard of it um that
is because it seeks to mend a loophole
in our statutory language that
undermines our own individual campaign
Finance
limits in a June 2023 New Hampshire
bulletin article on New Hampshire
campaign Finance changes I found this
quote quote individuals have always been
able to find ways to skirt campaign
Finance limits in the state argued Greg
Moore the state director for Americans
Prosperity New Hampshire a conservative
advocacy group one popular way is
through the use of quote limited
liability corporations that individuals
can form to increase their donations a
process reformers call the LLC
loophole so Mr Moore is saying that if
an individual who has a limit of
$115,000 over three different reporting
periods per campaign cycle per candidate
wants to skirt that individual limit
then they can create an LLC or shell
Corp to hide the fact that they are
bundling money to give more than the
legal limit but that is a bad habit we
have allowed to take root and clearly it
is not the intent of the
law the Law's intent is to place some
restriction on escalating costs of
Elections which as anyone who identifies
as fiscally conservative must admit is
an incredible waste of money at this
point um where does it end if anyone can
flout the rules and we as a legislative
body who continue uh continue to look
the other way this bill seeks to add the
transparency necessary to know who is
contributing what via the New Hampshire
Secretary of State's campaign Finance
reporting system if you are part of an
LLC we should have your name uh and
contact information when a political
donation is made not an innocuous shell
Corporation that's specifically designed
to sidestep the disclosure of donor
information and everyone else uh has to
follow that everyone else has to follow
if there are three people involved
involved in the LLC they get onethird of
the donation attributed to them so
individual limits can be tracked as the
law
intends HB
1074 asks that we provide some direction
for the secretary scanland office in
order that in order to remove the guess
work in whether an LLC is actually just
a Dodge of the campaign Finance rules
llc's are designed to remove Li ility
from individuals for Investments and
other Financial transactions the LLC is
a protection uh for the individual but
it was never designed to provide a cloak
of secrecy for donors in campaign
Finance systems and that requires
everyone else to be transparent about
where election money
originates if we want people to have
faith in us and their elections we
should recommend HB 1074 out of
committee OTP to make clear that
everyone plays by the same rules when we
create Financial limits on contributions
we need to require the disclosures that
allow us to verify that donors are
working within state law thank
you okay we've taken questions from the
committee oh be happy to all right other
questions from the
committee representative
qualey thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for speaking with us
today uh I'm aware that some C's can
consist of Partnerships with multiple me
Members I don't know of an upper limit
there could be three four or
five uh suppose we have a scenario where
in in Partnerships in my experience are
typically divided by a vote of the
decisions are made by votes of the
members uh suppose we have a member of
an LLC partnership who was outvoted by
the other members and did not have any
wish to contribute to a particular
candidate does it seem right that that
person should be ascribed a
contribution having made a contribution
when they that person had no desire to
do so thank you thank you for the
question it's an interesting question
there are definitely um going to be
unique scenarios and edge cases as with
any any law um the idea really is to say
if you are if you are part of an LLC is
making a contribution that contribution
needs to be adequately attributed so I
I'm not sure that person would be happy
if they were donating to a candidate or
a cause that that person wasn't
interested in or didn't support but I
think that that does not negate the need
for transparency around who is
contributing the money and how it should
be attributed so the example that I gave
of three
contributors it's just math right no
matter how many folks are in that LLC
you can divide the money uh so that you
know and um and what it really is
designed to do is just stop that
bundling that is clearly not the intent
of the
law further questions represent
we thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um just kind of a
followup to the previous
question um uh for instance down in line
29 it talks about the amount of the
contribution attributed to each member
so you're you are you would anticipate
that an LLC
could allocate different portions and
not just
average the amounts out to to all
members but could actually assign it to
various members or do
you it would be it would be allocate
allocated evenly amongst the number of
members is the way I I believe the
wording okay that's what it means I
think so it couldn't it couldn't be
followup uh Mr chair uh representative
Lane has her hand up so she gets to go
first if she was so
choose I was going to say my
understanding of the law was that in
fact if if if it's
divided 30 20 whatever 50 that it would
be divided up in that manner and if it
wasn't clear that it would be presumed
to be a third a third a
third just that okay I assume there'll
be a followup to that
one so you're saying it can be
designated if if different members of an
LLC want more of it attributed to them
is well the the have may I ask yes um
thank you the LLC agreement would would
um allocate it within the members so
that not they may not have all equal
membership they may have it may be like
I said 30 20 50 or whatever you come up
with and if they're going to give out
money then they would divide it up that
way most llc's are are are not making
political donations it's a very specific
kind so you wouldn't probably run into
this problem too often
thank you does anyone else have any
questions before we go back to
representative wary all right let's just
keep the show going
rep thank
you I can I can thank
you thank you thank you for the
compliment um so um again following up
on uh the previous questions so if if
there are different levels of ownership
within the LLC or the
Partnerships and you know a a 10% member
might have 10% of a contribution
allocated to them versus someone who
owns 90% say um
or the LLC could choose to designate
when they provide this information the
respective contribution levels do you
see anything I mean that would still get
at the intent you don't want an
individual contributing beyond their
stated amount under uh
um
so it do you do you see that this could
be worded in such a way to account for
those
factors I think that the language that
is here which has gone through several
iterations since I've been in the
legislature is sufficient for the
Secretary of State's Department to
Institute it I know that in I I'm in the
electronic campaign Finance system and
um there are some folks who are opting
to give to multiple candidates very low
amounts of money so I'm getting you know
a163 or something you know I'm getting
uh notices of of small amounts of money
electronically that are being donated to
my account through act blue which is a A
system that helps you know donations to
democratic causes and so the systems can
do the math what we're asking for is
that we put in place a requirement that
there be an accounting of who's doing
what and that they acknowledge that so
that there's
transparency and what will happen is if
someone is contributing in multiple
places in multiple amounts it will all
go to them just like it does in the
regular you know any any regular
contributor in the campaign Finance
system who puts um you know when we put
our donations in from different
individuals uh that system is capable of
calculating how much money the
individual has provided to individual
causes and candidates so it wouldn't be
any different uh for this they can do
it you want to go again yeah all right
so so does that risk so in the scenario
that I laid out before Grant it is a
hypothetical but could you sort of
disenfranchise the
10% owner by by averaging out the
contribution and then they would not be
able to contribute more to their
preferred
candidate no I think the actual 10% is
what would be would is what would be
attributed to that person so the the
LLC may be the donor but once you create
transparency with the people behind the
LLC then the contribution per individual
will only be calculated based upon what
percentage is attributable to them so if
was a 10 if was a $10,000 donation and
$1,000 was was representative we's um
then that is all that would be
attributed to you and so the balance of
your individual campaign limit would
still be available to you and that's
really the point of the
Bill okay thank you
okay um further questions uh
representative
Howard thank you so much for taking my
question uh when we're talking about
contributions are we talking about
direct contributions or independent
expenditures uh direct contributions
okay thank you
sure further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
represent McGee uh next up will be our
own representative Lane who's decided to
enter the
fry uh thank you uh Mr chair I'm a
co-sponsor of this bill and um I can't
testify from up there to answer
questions so I thought it would be
better for me to be sitting here um my
name is Connie LAN I am uh from
conquered War I marac District uh 16 so
the the bill as U representative McGee
indicated is all it's transparency it's
to allow people to be
transparent most of these types of llc's
are not the kind of llc's that most of
us think about where there's a
partnership or a small one they're
created specifically to get around
this I know representative qua hates
this term this loophole or this way to
get
around the the limitation in the amount
and so if you look down at the bottom
it's on pay on number 27 so what happens
is when the limited liability company
contributes it provides the recipient
with the names and the addresses and
that all goes into the campaign Finance
system and that's how it
recorded so that's how the Secretary of
State and the campaign Finance um system
will keep track of it and so to answer
you know representative we's concerns
yes it is possible that that one person
could get the 10% but I would like to
think that in a partnership that they
would not do that to their own
partner yes it would be possible but
again this law is not really directed at
a typical LLC that we all tend to think
about and organize and give limited
liability for people who are you know
running their own business so these are
for people who do this on purpose to
funnel money to political action
campaigns or to political campaigns and
to make them be transparent that's the
goal I assume you'll be taking questions
from the Comm oh yes sir oh yes all
right representative we we'll keep the
The Show Goes On
I I've been waiting to ask
representative Lane questions for for a
long time long time so um so to that to
that
end um yeah the the principle here is is
good but but um I'm just wondering if
there might be a better way of of
working it around do you think there
might be a better way of working it
around by
more clearly identifying the purpose of
the LLC in its initial registrations or
things like that if they're creating
shell companies to do that facilitate
this should the law be directed more
toward the creation of the LLC and the
registration process there or or does it
belong in election law I just I'm yeah
curious I guess I hadn't thought about
it that way but my concern is that most
LC's when they form they have a clause
that says in any other legal reason to
do business in the state of New
Hampshire so there's a catchall clause
So in theory any one of them could do
that they usually State the primary
reason so if the primary reason is a you
know auto part store or mechanic or
whatever that's the primary reason but
in theory they could go out and and they
can give money too so but it it's a good
I don't know if it solve the problem
totally but you know we could ask that
for people to do it but I'm not sure
what the enforcement mechanism would
be representative Bay
first thises this probably just from
ignorant thank you Mr chair um when you
form an
LLC uh you can do it in any state or do
you have to do it in New Hampshire
correct so you can do it
in
yeah well now we have to go back to
representative weary and got do this
back and forth weirdness can I yield to
you can y yeah absolutely yeah represent
B go back it's a courtesy you know
I'm thank you
representative so if um wouldn't you say
that if we're going to
um uh
Implement something such as okay you
have to to state that this LLC is uh
formed for for this particular purpose
then effectively you're making all of
the states do that and and make that
part of the questionnaire when you form
an LLC which is like not within the
realm of what we can do in New Hampshire
actually no it would only we can only
govern New Hampshire llc's most people
actually form well I shouldn't say most
many people form their llc's in
Delaware um because it's better known
the laws the courts are more favorable
to businesses and um everybody's pretty
familiar with them so um but the fact
that they would have to
still in this act they would still have
to
report whether they're Delaware
California West Virginia whatever they
would still have to report to the
recipient and and how many you know and
and what people are
donating okay nice try though further
questions
all right we'll keep going all right so
um
so so the r it so the legal status it
sends up in line one RSA 304
so you're saying we could apply this to
other llc's formed in other
states no well the reporting under the
last the on line 27 when a limited
liability contributes it has to provide
the recipient of the contribution with
the names and addresses of all
members so that's a campaign Finance
provision I don't think that it is a
necessarily a formation question which
is I think what representative Bay was
getting to it's it's a fine
difference it has to do with campaign
Finance as opposed to LLC formation sure
I I'd be curri thank you Mr chair I'd be
curious about the applicability I mean
it'd be a good question to to understand
from the Secretary of State or attorney
general how you know whether or not
that's really
applicable um because I I mean I can see
it being
applicable right for New Hampshire but I
I can't I can't see and the and you
talked earlier about the enforcement
mechanism I would also find that
challenging to to enforce in that
context I I think you just gave us our
homework I Tred oh Lord okay further
questions from the committee
representative rafter um yeah just one
uh clarification I guess in lines four
and five going back to the allocation of
the contributions it refers to allocated
as provided in RSA 6644 so that would
determine the allocations based on each
member's investments in the LLC okay
which is governed by the LLC
agreement
okay okay further question of the
committee seeing now representative
qu I knew that was too easy I
tried thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Lane for taking my
question uh I understand your concern is
stated about uh I won't restate it but I
understand it how many instances are you
aware of where an LLC has been used in
the fashion that that you oppose please
I will defer I know that I've read a lot
of articles but I don't remember the
number but I'm going to defer to some of
the folks who are going to speak because
they do know how many times I think
there's a Dunkin Donuts there's a law
there's a a law there is a law article
law review article that goes into depth
about how many times it's used and it
continues to be used thank you okay okay
further question of the committee now
seeing none thank you representative
Lane uh next next up will be the person
who will probably answer representative
qu's question Olivia
zinc good morning again do I I'm a
Franklin voter open democracy executive
director I won't go you've heard that
that just half an hour ago um so I want
to speak in support of this bill um and
just um maybe I'm going to start not
talking about my testimony but maybe
give an example
so representative Barry maybe decides to
run for governor and I want to support
representative Barry and his goo notori
campaign and I and representative
Brennan have a business that we own 50%
of and we give a $10,000 check to
representative Barry 15,000 15,000 yeah
I want 15 well well we're going to do
10,000 first right so representative
Brennan and I give $10,000 5,000 is
allocated to me 5,000 is allocated to
Angela Angela personally gives
$10,000 to Barry that's her
$155,000 limit that's all she can give
if uh I don't know representative Mirad
and Angela have
another LLC that they want to give money
to representative Barry from She's hit
her limit so basically what this is
doing is ass signing people that
$15,000 cap that they C whether it's a
personal donation or an LLC donation if
representative Brennan really wants to
funnel $100,000 into representative
Barry's campaign for governor she can
just create a super pack and put
$100,000 into a account right she
doesn't have to use multiple llc's to
funnel monies there's other ways that
that that she can get $100,000 to
representative Barry for his gorial
campaign um just saying I just use that
as an example for a little levity in
this comedy to just sort of talk about
what this is trying to do um and you
know when representative Barry runs for
governor he might come for looking at
both of us for money
um um so I just want to talk a little
bit about the history of this I started
looking at this when there was a $7,000
limit now it's a $115,000 limit so we've
increased the limits but we're still
seeing llc's break the law um I'm going
to go back to
2010 where John Ste Stevens who was a
candidate in the primary received
$100,000 from 30 limited liability
companies in two addresses one in
Connecticut and one in Massachusetts so
here's two out of state companies that
are funneling 100 ,000 into a campaign
for governor and this is in 2010 mind
you remember like campaigns weren't as
as expensive as they are now um I'm also
going to use another example that on
August 18th uh 13 llc's at the same
address in Massachusetts gave gorial
candidate Kevin
Smith um nearly half of what Kevin Smith
raised so
$324,000 in contributions from an LLC
um there's also uh what representative
Lang talked about is the $999,000 from
50 llc's which are also Dunkin Donuts
franchise and then there's also $55,000
from donations in that two that same
2010 um campaign from 11 addresses in
Newington and Yonkers New York which
were Planet Fitness franchises so I want
to say that this is I used Uh Kevin
Smith and John Stevens in 2010 but the
Democratic candidates use this too it's
not just Republican candidates for
Governor that use this it's used by both
sides both sides equally exploit this
loophole um Kevin landrian reported um
in
2012 um this is my the favorite example
I have with llc's so decking
18639 LLC decking Atlantic 1720
and then there was all kinds of
different decking companies with
different numbers Associated giving
different amounts of money but there
were 47 checks all associated with the
82 Flanders Road um Westboro
Massachusetts apparently westbo
Massachusetts got uh representative
Barry is where you want to go for those
big
checks
um so um I also give an example of
um uh when uh Dan felt this ran for
governor in 2020 um a few different
llc's that had funneled money into his
campaign so this is a fairly Common
Sense Bill you've seen past bills I
listed them there's a lot of times this
bill has been tried and I feel like it's
gotten better every single time it's
been introduced it's gotten you know
worked out the Kinks so I think it's
ready uh for an a to pass so that we can
close this loophole um finally and get
this uh behind us and happy to take any
questions
okay all right any questions other than
me running for governor all right no
questions all right all right thank you
thank you and thank you for a little bit
of levity I do appreciate that campaign
Finance can be awfully dry and I do
appreciate a good lap um next up we'll
go with Katherine langville langel
excuse me I always want to add a v to
your name for no
reason
cool so you also heard about me about a
half an hour ago but uh for the record
I'm Katherine LEL I um yeah it's okay um
uh yeah I'm open democracy actions
public policy fellow um I am testifying
today in support of uh HB also I will um
address a typo on my written testimony I
wrote HB 1047 instead of
1074 so please note that um I
apologize
um after reviewing the bill um I bring
forward a suggestion for a small
Amendment to the proposed bill um former
Representative Bob Perry um who's a
former member of election law um
actually brought this forth to my
attention um in lines 6 12 16 22 and 26
the current bill cites RSA
6644 Section 5 as describing
contribution limits um however that
paragraph outlines contributions for um
any candidate committee or political
advoc advocacy program as unlimited for
three phases um the paragraph of this
paragraph four of the same RSA describes
contribution limits um for a person or
corporation uh that would place Total
maximum contributions at $155,000 which
was what we were discussing so my
proposition is that every mention to
section or paragraph five is just
changed to paragraph four um as I think
it would uh fit the intention of this
bill more appropriately um otherwise I'm
going to defer to my Superior elivia
zinc
who uh provided a significant amount of
context on the background for this bill
um I'm happy to take questions
though good catch
um other any questions from the
committee okay seeing none thank you oh
I'm sorry representative
weary
um so just Googling
6644 yeah uh section four was repealed
and it is Section Five that talks about
the contribution limits
so yeah so I'm
not
I'm I'm I'm a little confused with this
because it looks like Roman numeral 4
has been repealed okay in the law and
that it is Section Five that talks about
although your comments about its
applicability May pertain but I I
just Googled it and these things are
fluid as we know so absolutely that's
understandable but I just um you may
want to provide an update or something
to to that effect thank you yeah
definitely um I apologize if that was uh
incorrect I had checked gen court and
the
rsa's um kind of portal there the other
day so um yeah hopefully or I guess the
applicability still uh stands true in
checking and making sure we're citing
the right thing
but I appreciate your time thank you
okay further questions for the committee
seeing none thank you so much last up is
Liz tantarelli from the New Hampshire
League of Women
Voters good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Liz
tenter trelli I'm president of the
nonpartisan League of Women Voters of
New Hampshire and we have as part of our
mission campaign Finance reform so I've
been testifying on bills like this for
several years I do want to point out
that in
2019 Senate Bill 156 attempted to do the
same thing and it passed the house 212
to
139 uh um obviously passed the Senate it
was one of the 57 bills however that
Governor sonunu vetoed that year when he
was exercising his red pen and if I knew
how and if I had the time i' try to find
out how many of the governor's campaign
contributions came from multiple
llc's but I don't know how to do
that uh however I think there must have
been sumon there um this bill does not
stop people from donating to candidates
of their choice but it does prevent
wealthy influencers from create from
using multiple llc's to get around the
campaign Finance donation
limits found an article last year where
one member of the House publicly stated
I believe that money is speech and so
I'm opposed to placing limits on that
well I'm not just because one person has
more money doesn't mean he should have a
louder
voice the property owner in town who
pays the most taxes for his Lakeside
estate still gets only one vote in local
elections that's the way we think it
should be and so this is a bill that
attempts to fix that in my testimony
second to the last paragraph I quote an
article from 2021 the conquered monitor
at that time there were about
65,000 New Hampshire llc's in good
standing they constituted the vast
majority of New Hampshire business
entities except for the sole
proprietorships whatever they may be but
at least
75% of those LL C's had a single member
and 20% had only two members so that
means at least in theory in
2021 60,000 people could have made
multiple donations above established
donation limits I'm not saying they did
I think uh Miss zinc's testimony is more
accurate on that but this talks about
the possibilities so with that I urge
you to support this Common Sense bill
that we have been looking at for years
if there are questions I can answer I
would be pleased to all right questions
from the
committee representative weing did the
uh article uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question thank
you for your testimony um in
the conquered monitor article did they
say whether or not they had done the
research as to finding duplicate
instances of owners of the
llc's um so there's they're saying that
this is the breakdown in the
demographics of single single member
llc's and multi-member llc's or two
member llc's but did they do their
homework and actually distinguish that
there were multiple llc's because this
is the this is the issue that I
understand right so did they actually do
that
homework I'm sorry I can't answer that
right right now I'd have to go back and
dig up that article again I do give the
date and uh we might be able to find it
so the date is in my testimony but right
now I can't answer that but thank you
follow up yeah uh just um for the record
again could you please tell me the date
of that article because I just
um uh as a single member LLC person um I
don't really I I hate to cast aspersions
upon our llc's in New Hampshire I would
do that yes of course not no I'm sure I
mean llc's are formed for numerous
reasons and you know I'm not denying
that that I'm not saying they shouldn't
exist this is solely about contributions
the date was November 15th
2021 in the conquered monitor thank you
very much I I just if I may for the
record I have not formed an LLC for the
governor Barry campaign yet so uh the
emphasis there's yet um okay thank you
seeing no other questions thank you Mr
tanelli that concludes our people are
our that concludes our public testimony
from those signed up to speak in person
online there were 70 in support and four
opposed with that I will be closing the
public hearing on House Bill 1074 I'll
be immediately opening the house the
hear public hearing on House Bill um uh
1 1119 relative to absentee ballots uh
representative prud home O'Brien is
recognized representative O'Brien would
you get a moment can you send me a pink
card and representative Lane will be
rejoining us
valiantly good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I always forget
the pink card when I'm in introducing a
bill because it just seems so obvious of
course I'm going to be
speaking so I'll get that yes um so I I
thought this was a
rather boring bill in a
sense and it just simply addresses an
issue that came up in my community where
we did have the the winter storm in the
uh Municipal
elections yet the the uh absentee ballot
request form did not have a section for
people to check off so there was some
confusion when people didn't want to be
um dishonest about why they were
requesting this form uh requesting an
absentee ballot and they didn't feel
that they were that these things applied
to them I am elderly or infirm I have a
physical disability otherwise would I
would vote in person but I have concerns
for my safety um
[Music]
traveling in the storm that seems to be
saying that they are elderly and infer
infirm you don't you don't have to be
elderly or infirm or have a physical
disability to have those safety concerns
uh in the storm or that you are caring
for a child or an adult in need so this
takes that section out and would simply
add I would otherwise vote in person but
I have con concerns for my safety
traveling in the storm and this is to
clarify um to go back a little bit that
is when the national weather service has
issued a winter storm warning blizzard
warning or ice storm warning for
election day that is applicable in the
city town or un Incorporated place that
the person is residing in and requesting
the absentee ballot
in I just spoke to Secretary of State
scanland and he says that he signed in
in favor on this bill and he like likes
the space saving um part of this bill
that it takes it although it adds it
does take away some of the um lines that
are in there right now and it IT
addresses the issue so that that voters
can feel that they're being completely
honest as they fill out this form and I
I know that most voters and our state
would want that uh it there's an
additional
section that is added that says during a
a storm warning the Monday before an
election the clerk's office May remain
open later or otherwise extend its hours
I know that this is a concern in in my
community where we have many people that
are coming from out of town uh where
they work and voting you know
maybe um something that they want to do
after 5:00 p.m. and and if our town
clerk would um be amenable to that um
that's what would they would they would
choose to do so if there are any
questions I'd be happy to answer them
and I think we may have some other
people signed up so they can answer them
as well question from representative
Lane um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative didn't we have this in
here once before because I recall our
first year on the committee yes that we
worked because there were two towns that
had this issue so was it taken out at
some point and now we're trying to put
it back in or am I misremembering I
think you might be thinking about the
addition so so I'm on page two yeah and
the part that would be taken out on line
one and two I'll read the whole thing I
am elderly or infirm or I have a
physical disability and would otherwise
vote in person but I have concern for my
safety traveling in the storm maybe
you're thinking about when that was
added and I and what happened in in
reality was that people felt they had
concerns for their safety traveling in
the storm but they weren't elderly or
infirm and had a physical disability and
they didn't want to check that off
because they were otherwise healthy and
they just wanted to be really really
accurate and honest in why they were
requesting an absentee
ballot and follow up yep um the top of
page two then the strike of that other
one is that not is that tied in or
because that's not really related to a
storm correct is it correct so this
would CLE clean that up and people could
simply write I would otherwise vote in
person but I have concerns for my safety
traveling in the storm that's it the end
I mean you could have concerns for your
safety based on just traveling in the
storm you could have concerns because
you have to bring your children to
school or to something or back from
school or all these things you're not
this just makes it it more clear for
people and clarifies it so that they
feel that there's a spot it was also
confusing when it's confuses the voter
to not have a spot that really applies
to them right I don't want that thank
you yeah F questions from the committee
representative
Burnham thank you Mr chairman um so in
my town a few years ago there was a big
storm and the town moderator chose to
cancel against the wishes of the
Secretary of State I believe but it was
was quite a a bit of snow and uh for the
safety they they chose to cancel and
reschedule so when that happens um and
someone decides that they were going to
say this goes in and they decide to do
an absentee ballot and then it's
rescheduled and now they want to go in
physically do you see that as being um
problematic thank you very much that's a
good question no I don't because there
are procedures in place that would show
that the person has already voted
absentee for clarification you do have
the ability to if you have voted by
absentee ballot to show up and remove
your absente about I think before 10:
a.m. on an election day maybe noon um
but you there's a time frame to show up
before election day to remove your
absente about if you've castone wish to
change it um further questions from the
committee representative qua uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
prome O'Brien uh this is more of a a
recollection regarding a a p bill that
was just referenced we did pass a very
similar Bill two years ago in the
previous bium uh which made it through
the house and then was uh altered
sufficiently in the other chamber of the
legislature that the house no longer
agreed with it and if I if I may I'd
also like to point out that the uh
winter weather provision in the RSA
itself that specifies the eligibility
makes no reference to whether you're
infirm or handicapped it just it uh so
leaving that out of this application
would actually be in stronger agreement
with the uh the underlying irsa spelling
out eligibility so I can make this a
question were you aware of that it's
hard to keep track of everything and I
thank you for that clarification that
really helps thank you thank you
representative Lane sorry um I um on
page one at 31 I I think that we we
don't need to check one because
you've you know there's only one so and
it says either and it says check one so
I think it's
just and so there's no choice to check
so I think it just it's a typo I think
we could have an amendment that's always
fun thank you for giving me all that
more extra work we could do that I
wanted to share the well since I had to
I could tell you're a
lawyer only one to
check okay further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative prom O'Brien got to give
me your pink card yes sir um Daniel
Richard is up next from Auburn New
Hampshire I have prepared uh that's fine
you can uh just bring it over there if
anybody has prepared testimony uh huge
pet peeve of mine is the distribution of
written testimony while somebody's
testifying it's like a huge pet peeve so
if you have written testimony do me a
solid give it to representative uh
anenberg at the beginning of the bill
hearing um and we will distribute it out
um and that way because I I find it very
disrespectful when people are doing this
one right while somebody's talking um
want you you're here we'll keep the
focus on you um so just just an FYI
that's how I like it and I'm sticking to
that thank thank you committee members
thank you for giving me your time today
uh I want to address this issue I oppose
this bill for a variety of reasons first
of all lack of jurisdiction the state uh
the state constitution is very clear it
was amended in 1942 specifically to
provide for absentee voting and within
that provision it provides the two
constitutional exemptions the last time
I checked this body has never been
granted the ability to create a
constitutional right to an absentee
ballot it's it's a big deal it's in the
Supreme Court now and to courot to quote
chief justice Gordon McDonald on the
29th of November when questioning the
state's attorney he asked the state's
attorney permissible legislative
judgment please explain to me what that
means because I don't understand how is
how is it permissible for the
legislature to ask to exercise
permissible legislative judgment when it
exceeds the authority of the
Constitution he was spot on what's
happened recently just so that this
committee is aware the state on that
same day the state supreme court cited
morvi Harper morvi Harper is the
redistricting fight that's now settled
so it's now settled in the state by that
Federal Supreme Court decision within
that body it specifically spells out
what I'm saying to you this body is
specifically limited by your Authority
granted in the Constitution now we have
a bigger problem with absentee ballots
I'd like to bring to your attention what
I handed out to the committee is
starting with article 11 the Bill of
Rights the private rights of the people
within that scope is the Mandate for
this body to create the necessary
statutes and rules and regulations to
conduct your elections but remember
whenever this body acts it acts with
Federal oversight as well because you're
in concurrent jurisdiction the Article 1
Section 8 excuse me Article 1 Section 2
says that the people of the several
States shall elect their Federal
representatives in Article 1 Section 4
which is what morv Harper is all about
about addresses that issue in great
detail so here's what I want to bring to
your attention what we don't have
happening right now who knows what an
affidavit
is you're an attorney right an affidavit
just for the record is a legal
instrument sworn before a public
official authorized by law to do so we
currently have and have had since
absentee voting was created in
1942 a notary certificate requirement
and that currently exists in statute 659
colon 30 which says and I will quote
it and this is in the challenge voter
section and by the way you can't
challenge it if it isn't properly
notorized
affidavit the Affidavit of a challenge
voter or asserting a challenge form a
qualified voter affidavit we all know
the qva or any other affidavit required
by elction
statutes it has to be sworn before an
official authorized by law they give you
five people to do it in front of a
notary a JP the moderator the selectman
and the clerk those are all the the
prerequisites for that issue and it's
not happening so when you get to step B
when the moderator checks the absentee
ballots we have a huge problem step B
step B says that he shall I have to
pause you there we have to keep
testimony relative to the bill sure um
and I understand the argument you're
probably going to make about this is all
absolute ballots it's all connected I I
don't want I don't want this to turn
into something off the bill so we got to
you got to stay focused on
hp19 uh 1119 I'm sorry to do that to you
but that's all right so flurry of cards
come in so I'm I'm at the brink of
creating a Time rule for this bill so no
problem so the real issue is this if the
state constitution authorizes this
committee to write rules and regulations
for one that you are physically disabled
and by the way when this first went into
effect you had to have a notary
certificate from your doctor so this
committee what I'm saying to you is is
well- intended as dealing with the snow
what did they do in 1784 they got to the
polls on a
horseback okay so let's put that in
context and you must look at the State
Constitution the courts are very clear
both state and federal you have to look
at the State Constitution and the
Federal Constitution as they were
written at the time they were written
not in the modern era thank you any
questions thank you yes any questions
from the
committee um okay thank you thank you
all right all right next up is Linda
Callaway from New
Durham morning thank you for your
time I'm here as a town moderator
representing myself not necessarily the
town uh first of all I want to say I am
totally in favor of this bill um I think
uh making sure that people have the
right right to vote in spite of
especially weather conditions that are
unexpected um is definitely
necessary um I did want to bring up the
fact that there are some unexpected
unexpected consequences which can happen
because of this um our town had uh we
held our election during the um you know
the date it was is um
prepared and we had no option to cancel
it um our school would only let us use
the gym for that day and we have no
other building in our town which would
be able to handle the elections so we
went ahead we had um we had good um the
uh fire department was going to pull
their their truck around the back in
case we lost electricity so we had power
the police and the fire were willing to
you know get all our pole workers coming
in we stripped down as much as we could
but um again we were in very bad
conditions and and uh as a result of the
totally proper we had more than 50
people come in the day before so that
they were able to do the absentee
ballots we put it out on Facebook
everyone come in on Monday before it
starts so that we got as many votes as
necessary or as we could we still had a
turnout of over 300 people in the snow
which was pretty amazing but the thing
we had to remember is um when we put in
for our ballots we saved we want this
many absentee ballots this many same day
ballots okay in the statute if during an
election you run out of same day ballots
you can go ahead and use absentee
ballots and just the clerk can you know
cross off the absentee well we do not
have is the opportunity in an emergency
situation like this to just use same day
ballots for absentee ballots in order
for us to do that we have to make copies
of those which as you know will not go
through an Acu vote machine so as a
result of this we had more than 50 AB
extra absentee ballots with a paired
down staff in an
emergency we got an incredible amount of
snow um and so it meant that our pole
workers were there an extra hour hour
and a half dealing with those I have
some great pictures of us going through
the snow getting the stuff back into our
cars to get to the town hall at the end
of the night and it worked but the issue
was
um if we can use absentee ballots for
same day ballots there should be
something that says especially in an
unforeseen emergency we should be able
to do the same so some towns get around
this by saying they they put in extra
they they order extra absentee ballots
versus same day ballots so they can do
that which I don't understand that's
some kind of a counting thing that now
you're skewing the numbers as to how
many absentee versus whatever
so basically um I just wanted to let you
know I totally agree we should have this
but a simple thing of allowing that same
day ballots can be used in in the space
of absentees if you run out especially
in emergency and all it would take is
one extra line on the moderator's
worksheet to say and right now we have
absentees used as same day ballots you
could have same day ballots used as
absentee I know everyone's cringing
about another line but this is simple
simply an accounting error now a couple
things may happen with the new um I
don't know how many people are still
going to be using the ACU votes after
this year um I know that you know we're
anticipating new machines coming out
which are which may not make any
difference in what type of paper is
being used but for those towns that that
may not do that if we have an emergency
like that I think um that you need to uh
anticipate that there could be
unforeseen consequences and hazardous
conditions which would impact the safety
of the pull workers in such such a a
thing everyone worked out great everyone
came together but you know we were there
for like an extra hour and a half at the
end of the night trying to get
everything done and you know I had an
extra foot in my driveway by the time I
got home luckily someone helped me get
on my driveway so um anyway that's
that's all I have to say but I wholly
holy wholly uh support getting um the
absentees um more expanded usage if
anyone has any questions questions from
the committee see seeing none thank you
so much thank you um just so you know
the reason I was cringing is not uh on
their comment was because of the folds I
was having folds flashback oh
um
um uh next up is Al uh uh bran
brandano did I do well did I get it
right this time I I always go back and
fr thank you all right nailed
it thank you for having me um my name is
Al brandano I'm from Kensington New
Hampshire and I'm speaking and opposed
to this
bill I'm against this bill for really
virtually four reasons one it's
repugnant to the Constitution as you've
heard uh Mr Richards a uh constitutional
scholar here in New Hampshire to speak
to second the lack of the affidavit the
affidavit executed by a um a public
official which has always been required
and unfortunately has been taken off I
think maybe by mistake on the on the
absentee voter envelope I think when
they added all the pieces the new things
that they have added they knocked that
part off so something to think about or
look at three um you're awarding
privileges to people
that the special award there not fair
and equal treatment if someone can say
I'm not going to show up today because
of the weather and the weather doesn't
occur it's a whole problem with weather
I mean it's almost making this a joke we
can come for anything you check anything
on the absentee Bell at now and just
come and show up or not show up so
special privileges are being awarded
here and fourth the Moder Ator already
has the ability to stop an election or
postpone an election there's no need for
this it's already within the rsas it's
already within the power of the
moderator who really controls the
elections thank
you question from the committee
represent
Brennan thank you Mr chair are you aware
that on line 28 of this bill um which
remains unchanged in the
rsas happens before the line where you
would check I would otherwise vote in
person but I have concerns for my safety
traveling in the storm on line 28 of
this bill it says for use only on the
Monday immediately prior to the election
I cannot appear at my polling place on
Election Day because the national
weather service has issued a winter
storm warning blizzard warning or ice
storm warning for election day
applicable to my city town or
unincorporated
place are you aware that that restricts
the use of this checkline to only when a
National Weather Service when the
national weather service has issued a
specific kind of warning thereby
rendering this very limited
acceptability for absentee ballots are
you aware uh I just I have read it and
the part that I have to challenge with
you is where in the constitution does it
make any exceptions for weather it
doesn't so making it limited doesn't
make it
right further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you next up
is Tina Guilford Guilford excuse me from
Dair sorry throw that at
you good morning committee uh my name is
Tina Guilford I'm the dairy town
clerk
um this bill um 657 colon 4 creates the
form for applying for an absentee
ballot it uses references from RSA 657
colon 1 which is where the rules
are 657 colon 1 part two is when the
national weather service has issued a
winterstorm warning blizzard warning or
ice storm warning for election day
applicable to the city town or
unincorporated place
place it then gives you two choices in
the statute of RSA 657 colon 1 a a
person who otherwise would have voted in
person but has concerns for his or her
safety traveling in the storm shall be
considered absent for purposes of this
chapter and may vote absentee on the day
immediately prior to the election or B A
person who cares for children or infirm
adults who reasonably anticipates that
school child care or adult adult care
will be cancelled who would otherwise
have voted in person but will be debed
from voting by the need to care for
children or infirm adults shall be
considered absent for the purposes of
this chapter and may vote absentee on
the day immediately prior to the
election that's why there were two
choices on the
form however at some point in time that
I am elderly or infirm or I have a
physical disability was added but that's
not in 657 colon 1 and has caused a lot
of confusion in our town in
March forms should match the
statute so that is why this needs to be
fixed the other part of this
bill um allows for the clerk to stay
open in the case of a winter storm
warning past 5:00 p.m. and that's
because as you can see on page three
um line 21 it says as required by RSA
652 colon
20 that
RSA um requires whenever the election
laws require a filing with or an action
by the official such filing or action
shall be performed before 5:00 in the
afternoon on the stipulated
day so we would need permission in order
to stay open later and that's what this
would give and and for us in Derry a lot
of those people there was no snow
falling on Monday the flakes didn't
start till about 4:00 a.m. the next day
but the time to reschedule the election
is hard at 6:00 p.m. and we never know
which way the storms are going to go
they told us that they
expected somewhere between five to 8
Ines total over the course of the
day we got 16 in over the course of the
day so sometimes the winter storms are
not correct sometimes they say there's
snow coming and then no snow
comes so it's really really hard um
however we need the form to match the
statute and that's all and if there are
any questions representative Howard so
on uh on page two uh line three uh we
are striking out the uh anticipation
that people would need uh to care for
their children uh or uh infirm adults do
you think that that uh that that section
should remain uh in
statute well this the section is in
statute because that's 657 colon 1 um
when I spoke to representative prud home
O'Brien my thoughts were to just strike
the words in line one I am elderly or
infirm and I have a physical
disability okay because that's that
would match the statute in 657 colon one
all right awesome thank you so much
further questions representative
B do you think thank you chairman thank
you for taking the question do you think
the the weather and I believe in Darry
you did hold the election that day do
you think that the weather affected the
outcome of your
election do I think it affected the
outcome no um very sadly we have very
low
turnout in our local elections we have
19,000 voters and we normally get around
1,800 voters we got about a thousand
voters 300 of them voted an
absentee and and most of those were the
day
before um I don't know that it changed
the outcome at all
but I follow it okay uh seeing no other
questions thank you so much uh Liz
tantarelli you're up
next thank you I'm Liz tentarelli I'm
president of the League of Women Voters
and last year when town meeting March
town meeting occurred on a blizzard day
I uh eagerly the few days before started
alerting voters to this we used our
Facebook page I boosted posts to explain
the possibility of the early absentee
voting and I kept saying if a
winterstorm warning is posted and then I
updated it when that winter storm
warning was was
posted it's always interesting when you
boost something on Facebook to see what
kind of responses you get and the one
that I was most interested in is
somebody who said yeah but you have to
be really really old to get this to
apply to you I thought you know what's
with what's with people who who think
that the only people who are endangered
by trying to drive out in the snow are
really really old people now I don't
like to drive out in the snow and I may
be really really old but that's not the
point it could could be just as
dangerous for a perfectly hearty healthy
young person to try to walk the two
miles to the poles that they might
otherwise be able to do but their car
doesn't like
snow uh you know you you can be in as
much danger at age 25 as someone of my
age so I think getting rid of the
elderly and firm thing in here is very
necessary um and I got really tired that
year of arguing with people on Facebook
that look if you think it's too
dangerous for you to get to the
polls you still have a right to vote go
do it the night before that's what we're
trying to get to to that basic right so
I urge support of this Bill thank you
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up Daniel
Healey
hi uh Dan Healey uh NASA city clerk uh
representing the New Hampshire City and
town clerks
Association uh I'm going to be brief we
are in support of this bill I think
these are uh some good changes uh that
make it so uh more people can utilize
the absy uh ballot uh prior to the
election when there's going to be a
storm um representative prud O'Brien
represents Derry uh that's I'm a
resident there and um the issue that the
dairy town clerk mentioned with last
year's storm um was challenging for some
voters and at the time representative
prud om O Brien stated that she would be
proposing a change and I think this is a
good change to um not disenfranchise
some voters that may not meet these
first two uh qualifications
um so be open any questions questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thanks um last up is Olivia
zinc um good morning I'm Olivia zinc um
executive director for open democracy I
just want to quickly briefly mention
that Senate bill um
535 which is going to the senate floor
strikes the word I am elderly and or
physically disabled exactly what Tina
had requested um if the Senate passes
this on Thursday you might want to think
about this version um and not pass this
version or retain this version or
re-refer it um because um last year two
different versions passed and we lost
both of them in Committee of conference
so I'm just letting you all know that
Senate Bill
535 is a very similar bill um I really
want to thank the prime sponsor Kathleen
prudo Brom Ryan for this bill I think
it's very important um but I just wanted
to also just let you know that another
version very similar pass the Senate and
you might want to just take a look at
that I'm happy to take any questions
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you uh that's La uh represent AR
can you grab me the blue sheet I keep
forgetting I always forget to grab the
blue sheet I'm like the opposite of all
the other committee chairs they remember
the blue sheet forget the online I
remember the online forget the blue
sheet
all right is it
blank oh it's the first one that's not
blank all right so look at that very
serendipitous can't we use
them got these yeah okay testified one
two okay there were two people signed up
in person who did not testify they were
in favor of the bill online um it was 82
support four opposed and no neutral with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 119 I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
1133 going to hand the gavl to Vice
chairman bom so that I may introduce the
bill um
okay Ralph you got to hit the button
bro and recogn open the hearing on 11:33
and recognize representative
Barry
for Testimony okay uh thank you my name
is representative Ross Barry I represent
hilbo 39 um Manchester wward 689 the
south end I'm here to introduce House
Bill
1133 um what this does is it allows uh
uocava voters to email their absentee
ballot back in so we currently email it
to them uh then they print it off and
they have to mail it back to us um I
would like to see some amendments to the
bill we can go over that in executive
session um but my intention here is to
allow members of the military and their
spouses and their dependant um to be
able to send their ballots back in in
the same way in which they receive them
um there are some situations where it is
not practical for a member of the
military to mail their to print out and
mail their ballot back in the most
obvious one is if you're working on a
submarine um really hard to get Postal
Service underwater um so there are
examples of when this would um
when this would impact a military
voter's ability to send their ballot
back in I would like to see some
curtailing of the bill um I I want it to
apply specifically to members of the
military and their spouses Independence
um I don't want to open up the world to
mailing in absentee ballots um but I do
think it's appropriate if you're
overseas serving our country or you're
supporting your spouse who's serving our
country that You' be able to send that
ballot back in quickly um the other
thing that we'll need to add address is
it says via email is authorized by the
Secretary of State u in my kind of
exploration of this bill one of the
things I looked at was using an official
doj email right so we know it's coming
from the actual person that it was
emailed to uh the other thing that we
could obviously do is send it make it be
have to come from the same email that we
sent it to so there's some work we need
to do on the bill but I I appreciate the
and support the bill in concept um I
think it went through like two or three
revisions before I finally just told
alls sh ship it and we'll fix it um so
with that I'm happy to take
questions any
questions
represa I think you addressed my
question but I was going to ask you
about any concerns with use an email
yeah so you you you do you want to
elaborate on that a little more or do
you want to wait into wi session no no I
I I my concern is pretty much as I
stated right which is we have to be very
careful with this um we don't want to
open it up towards you know everybody's
emailing their ballot back in across the
state I'm a big fan of paper ballots um
I've said that several times um however
members of the military are different
they're treated differently they're
treated differently by the law um and I
once again to go back to to the
submarine example right there is if you
are underwater for 45 days in a
submarine which is very possible you
literally cannot get your ballot you
literally cannot you literally cannot
mail it back it is it is actually
physically impossible unless you're
going to give it to a dolphin so um
those sort of situations I think we can
address um but the committee will need
to be very careful in how we handle this
um but I do think it's a good
idea thank you my um my father was in
the Navy and sometimes you would call
ship to shore radio and I would talk to
him um he's never on a
submarine so I don't know how that works
exactly is there email I I think that
there is you need to ask somebody who's
in the military I am not um my I I
believe that they do can they can get
email but I could be wrong so I I think
we're already doing something
to help I think that I'm looking forward
to hearing from the Secretary of State
on this yeah they can get the email they
just because our current law require so
we email it to them currently that's we
currently do that what happens is they
print it out they fill it out and then
they mail it back that's the problem but
they can't mail and there are situations
where they cannot mail it back in
time any other
questions done
weing so um would you alter the
requirement to you know print it out and
scan it back in or would you I mean that
that that's what this bill does it
Alters the requirement to print it out
and scan it back in and allows them to
send it back in
electronically okay yeah so you would
have them fill out uh fillable flat file
or yeah we'll have to work on it right I
think that's I think that's an executive
that's an exact question um you know
it's I I do not believe the bill is
complete as written um certainly doesn't
address all of my concerns but it's I
think it's a subject worth worth talking
about in the
committee yes uh just as a curiosity
were you aware that you know government
agencies such as the Food and Drug
Administration take such forms like that
as a flat file oh fillable form and so
you I mean for registering products and
things like that oh yeah yeah I know
yeah I definitely used this I mean I use
this in my childcare setting right I
have a PDF that I send the parent and
they can just go through and fill
everything out in and they can check a
little checkbox or not check a checkbox
right there's definitely there
definitely ways that we can explore how
to do it we're going to have to we're
gonna have to do have that conversation
but there's definitely ways to do it I
believe one more if please follow up
yeah so uh and there are also a lot of
uh laws requirements and Technologies
around the concept of a of a digital
signature or an electronic signature so
those would also apply in this case once
again we'll have to have to sort all
that out in exec um because right right
now it says uh via email is authorized
by the secretary of state which is very
broad um and as you know I'm I'm a big
fan of ciling broad statements um so
definitely a conversation worth having
thank
you
thank you uh first I just want to say
thank you to the sponsor representative
Barry for um allowing me to co-sponsor
this bill uh supporting our military is
a bipartisan issue and I do believe that
is the intent of this bill and so I'm
grateful for that um I understand your
concerns and wanting to um make some
amendments and I'm just wondering if you
might consider working together on
amendments to make sure that this bill
remains a bipartisan Bill and that we
can address the issues that you have
seen and bring back something that can
still remain a bipartisan Bill oh of
course I'm always willing to work with
everyone thank you I'm known for
that that's why I be a great
Governor appreciate your
support okay saying no more questions
than we have quite a few people who want
to speak and represent bar could you
please fill out a pink
cart I thought that would get laugh next
next is Secretary of State David
scandin Secretary of
State um and I just want to offer some
information uh on this particular Bill
uh because I do have significant
concerns both in terms of the privacy of
the ballot uh and the security of the
transmission of the ballot uh I will
preface my remarks by saying that there
is no group out there uh that I would
like to be able to serve more than than
you know our servicemen uh that want to
vote using the uocava ballots
we have a similar uh situation with
individuals with site
disabilities and the uh our office has
been involved in litigation uh related
to you know how ballots are delivered
and received from that group of
individuals and we have uh settled that
with an agreement that we would provide
uh the ability to email ballots to
individuals with site
disabilities and we develop a program
that that individual can use on their
home computer where they can uh mark
their ballot but they have to uh print
it off and then mail it back to
us part of that discussion was well
can't they just email it back and uh the
settlement in that uh litigation was
that we would continue to monitor the
technology that's available to allow
that to
happen to make sure the ballots remain
private and uh secure from hacking and
things like that and we've engaged a an
expert in the field Harry hsty who some
of you may have heard of but he is
a uh a former hacker I hope he's still
not a hacker but uh turn consultant um
and we've utilized him in the past uh to
great advantage and uh you we trust his
judgment I will try and make available
to the committee the latest report that
he has issued on this subject because
you know uh part of the deal is that we
get regular updates on the status of
Technology uh to make this
happen
so uh that's where we stand with that in
terms of the bill
specifically uh there's a lot of there's
a a lot in here that needs to be
resolved um uh you know it it it gives
the broad authority to you know make
this process happen uh with receiving
ballots by email I would want to come up
with a process uh that is transparent up
front so that everybody knows how those
ballots are going to be handled uh I
would want to see them handled to the
least degree possible with as few
possible individuals uh seeing those
ballots so that we can maintain the
privacy of them I'm not quite sure how
that would work at the moment but uh
that would be a great concern uh and
then the other part of this is the
technology that we we would use to
receive these ballots and uh and
properly treat them it may be
appropriate to study this uh and I'd be
happy to participate um in a study
committee and you know bring in the
experts that we're using to help further
just this
discussion um but that's kind of where
we're at at the moment so i' be happy to
answer any
questions any questions represent brenon
thank you are you aware of any other
states that treat yava ballots um in the
way that this bill proposes with
submitting that completed ballot via
email or a secure Dropbox or something
of the like I'm aware that other states
do have programs I'm not familiar with
how they work but I see that Warren
Perry is here and he may be able to uh
offer some more information in that
regard we'd certainly be happy to look
at and see how other states are dealing
with this followup
please um would it be your advice that
if we are to amend this bill that the
perhaps that the effective date would
provide you a little bit of time to
figure out how other states are doing it
to make sure that Granite State military
service members have the same
opportunity that they are that is
available to them in other states
certainly delaying it would give us you
know more time to come up with a plan
thank
you uh thank you Mr secretary um would
it be necessary in the bill to go
through all the technology and all the
details of all that or is that something
that might be best left to your office
or someone else because you know we
write it and probably 18 months after we
write it it's going to be you know out
of
date we we're rapidly advancing the
technology that we have in the
department we don't have the expertise
to really look at the techn
technological components and so we have
to rely on other sources for that and
first instance is we look look at the
standards that's the that the that the
federal election assistance commission
is setting for the different types of
Technology that's out there and then we
look to National Certified National
Laboratories you know that can look at
the inner workings of computer code and
and Technology to you know give the
approval on whether it's actually
working or not this case would be no
different follow up just make sure that
I understood so
we could we don't have to lay out the
very detailed technological pieces in do
and all that in the statute we just need
to make sure that the correct standards
are perhaps referenced or something like
that it would be helpful to recognize
you know whichever agency sets the
standards for this I I think the the
part that we would be most concerned
about is what is the process going to be
for receiving
right you know the return ballots how
are we going to you know get that
information to the cities and towns how
is it going to be dealt with at the
local level um you know and those are
all an unanswered questions at this
point okay thank you represent Brant
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question have you ever heard from
someone who said I wanted to vote but I
was on a sub for more than 45 days and I
was unable to do so
I'm not recalling a conversation like
that but that's not to say that it
hasn't
happened follow
up do you know of other states doing
something similar to this specifically
to help uh military members overseas I
am aware that other states what are they
doing yes I I couldn't tell you which
ones but as I mentioned Warren Perry is
here um and he may be able to answer
that question
and he's next represent where we got
limit questions
here so if if our if in
the bill we we simply
limited the attributes to secure
transmission and authentication of
the of the individual submitting the
vote would that be sufficient or give
you sufficient leeway to Institute the
Technologies appropriate to fulfill
those C uh
characteristics if you want to implement
this sooner rather than later then I
think you would have to give broad
discretion to the Secretary of State to
uh handle this and if you're asking me
how I would handle it you know I would
want to have a a limited
secure
transmission probably to one
one uh you know receiving point in this
country because these ballots would be
coming from all over the world and then
we would have to figure out a way to
disseminate you know from the Secretary
of State's office how do we get that
information uh to the polling places so
that those ballots can be counted on the
day of the election
um I think it's going to take some
thought to figure that out but that that
I think that would be the quickest way
to get this up and
running followup last
one so
um are would you be comfortable with the
Secretary of State's office being
responsible for the authentication of
the
voter I think we could do that yes okay
thank
you thank you seeing no more questions
uh thank you for your test Tony and
we'll be working next on the list is
with who you mentioned is Warren
Perry of the military Affairs and
veteran
services good morning Mr chair I didn't
know that the secretary was GNA throw me
under the bus this morning so I'm happy
to be here but uh uh Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Warren Perry
I'm the deputy agitant general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services in that
role we service we uh are responsible
for the administration of the National
Guard both the Army and the air the
division of veteran services the Veteran
Cemetery and the Division of Community
Based military programs the department
supports the bill uh I don't need to say
more than that I think anything we can
do to make it easier for our military
members who are not in country for
whatever reason to vote the the better
off we are I mean it's just it's just
that simple to address the questions
that uh that were asked unfortunately I
don't know which other states have these
kind of uh bills or these kind of
processes but I'm sure that the other
ones do and they manage it appropriately
to to get this done but it is important
you know having been overseas uh as a
family member when my dad was stationed
overseas or you know as a as an army
officer you know whether I was in Saudi
Arabia or Germany or wherever it is the
ability to vote is probably one of the
most important things that we can do
whether you're in the service or not so
I would say that I will tell you that
that people are in places where they
don't have access to printers you know
and Christmas day in 2008 you know I
flew in a helicopter out to the marshes
in Iraq to deliver you know to deliver
Christmas cheer and those folks just
didn't have printers uh but they did
have access occasionally to email so
that they could get that done and they
can uh they can do that I'm sure you
know with all the technology we have in
submarines I guarantee that they can get
an email every now and then I'm pretty
sure so so subject to any questions you
might have I'll just uh end my statement
okay any questions good thank you and
question could you get us information as
to what other states are doing I can
work through that I mean generally we
don't deal too much in that but I we'll
take a look and I'll and I'll do my best
to get what I can work through the
Secretary of State's office I'll return
the favor of the
secretary okay thank you next person and
let's try to keep things short and keep
the questions limited and I will limit
questions is uh Kathy
right Kathy Holmes from Chai Chester I
am the campaign manager of your friend
representative Clayton wood but I'm
speaking for myself so um I remember the
20120 election when President Clinton
was the one and uh the leader up to that
the um the military bases places of
voting they were were shut down so that
they would have to use that APO address
that all goes to Florida and that was
the choke point all these military
ballots uh waiting there in Florida to
be counted also the mail on the ships at
Sea submarines or ships they that was
not being picked up their ballots were
there waiting to be picked up they were
never picked up until of after the
election and when that time passed every
they were checking for dented Chads oh
uh which was a form of ballot stuffing
the the military ballots were sitting
there not being counted so oh I'm in
support of this bill in case you
couldn't figure it
out questions thank you any
questions thank you next is Liz
tantarelli
hi Liz torelli from Newbury speaking
personally as the mother of a son who
has worked for the federal department of
justice for almost 20 years um and I'm
in support of this bill my son served a
year in Iraq a year in Afghanistan and
almost a year in Yemen just before
everything fell apart in Yemen and they
had to evacuate everyone so as
Department of Justice he is not military
but he does have the same issues of
voting when he was in Yemen they
received Courier mail only every three
weeks he wanted to vote but when at the
time when the ballot would have been
sent
out it didn't tie in with that 3-week
cycle so I support the bill but I hope
somebody can tell representative Barry
that he should not limmit it just to the
military thank
you thank you uh representative
Brennon thank you I agree um I look
forward to working on the amendment with
representative Barry are you aware that
there are 31 States including and
Washington DC and the Virgin Islands
that allow okaba voters to return voted
absentee mail ballots by fact and 25
States plus Washington DC in the Virgin
Islands allow uocava voters to return a
voted absentee mail ballot by email and
10 states allow okova voters to return a
voted absentee mail ballot through an
online
portal um are you aware of that thank
you for the question no I'm not aware of
it but I'm very pleased to hear that and
think that New Hampshire should join the
rest of the world great thank you thank
you okay thank thank you for Testimony
next is Paul Lloyd of
the state veterans advisory committee
good morning morning uh my name is Paul
Lloyd I'm the chairman of the state
veterans advisory committee our
committee is in full support of this um
this bill uh we want to thank the
sponsor for um changing the language uh
to include the female me uh the female
members the family members as well um so
again we are in support of this
Bill thank you any questions good thank
you next
is Liz Tabuchi or iuchi or I can't tell
the first
letter thank you Mr chairman uh it's Liz
yabuchi I'm actually from Asbury
Massachusetts but I'm here at today on
behalf of common cause and our more than
8,500 members here in the granite state
I'm actually appearing in opposition to
this bill and let me give you some
background on why uh New Hampshire to
date has not joined all of the other
states that have implemented some kind
of electronic ballot return I'm very
happy that New Hampshire has not joined
the bandwagon because it is not
something that technically can be done
safely right now I will get to you this
afternoon I will get to you a bulletin a
security bulletin issued by four federal
agencies that says that even with all of
the possible mitigations electronic
ballot return is high risk you're
risking the voter's in personal
information you're risking that the
ballots could be changed in
transit and there's no way to actually
guarantee that what is sent from
wherever it's sent from is what is
received um I'd like to give you some
background on how all of these other
states came to be uh allowing all of
this between 2010 pardon me between 2000
and 2010 the Department of Defense was
trying to create create a system that
would allow for the secure electronic
return of ballots they could not do that
they could not do that successfully so
during the time that they were working
on it lots of State P States passed laws
allowing for electronic ballot return
and they haven't rescinded them yet
despite the fact that the DoD said we
can't do this safely they have not
rescinded the laws
yet um I am going to get you the federal
agency uh risk assessment uh later today
I will also get you some testimony from
one of our partner
organizations
um and uh there are ways I we we are
very aware of the obstacles that people
overseas particularly the military we
are aware of the obstacles that people
face returning the ballots but there are
programs through the federal voter
assistance program through the EAC there
are programs that can help them that do
not risk the security or privacy of the
ballot when I talk about the security of
the ballot I just want you to keep in
the back of your mind what happens if
electronic ballots the number of
electronic ballots that cannot be
verified they cannot be audited they are
not secure they're not certain what
happens if that number
exceeds the margin of victory in a race
here in the granite
state if you have thousands of
questionable ballots you've got five
you've got about 15 thousand uh yava and
Military voters right now if you have
15,000 ballots that are returned
electronically and you are not sure if
those are the same ballots that were
sent how do you defend an election I'm
happy to take questions I know I know a
whole lot about this issue are there any
questions represent L uh thank you um
you mentioned an organization EAC is
that what what is that it's the US
election assistant commission okay thank
you and they have looked at this
issue okay thank you next is Kate
Hogan Hogan Hogan from secure
democracy good morning chairman boom and
members of the committing my name is
Kate Horan uh from got write the second
time you were you were very close the
first time sir
um and I want to thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony today
on behalf of secur democracy um I just
wanted to let the committee know I did
send all of you an email ncsl does have
a list of all of the states that I
believe representative Brennan was
looking at uh that lists all the states
that and how they do electronic ballot
return um about 27 states allow it via
email currently the rest offer a
combination of facts and or portal um
this I want to make clear does not
require a service member to return their
ballot electronically it is an option
that they have so if they know they're
returning their ballot electronically
they also know that their privacy on
that ballot is likely to be reduced that
is a choice that they are making um so I
think we want to keep that in mind um
also we want to make sure that New
Hampshire service members Independents
are able to have their votes counted
right now if they don't meet the window
for mail by 5:00 on Election Day their
votes aren't counted at all and these
folks are probably some of the most
important folks who should have that
option to vote and I want to make sure
this is not an expansive bill this is
not open it to everyone it is a very
specific group um one of thing I did
want to address is I know there's a lot
to talk about submarines that's not the
only option or potential conflict a lot
of service members right now especially
are in active hostile fire situations
and mail is not regular so they can't
guarantee that they will get their
ballots let alone be able to return them
in the amount of time that they have I'm
happy to take any questions um and happy
to assist in
anyway yeah thank you any
questions thank you thank you and two
more okay I call
David
Haley
name Daniel Hy I'm
sorry need my glasses uh Dan hilly uh
Nash city clerk uh representing New
Hampshire City and town clerk's
Association um we uh don't have a a
stance on this bill I just here to offer
some testimony um everything that
Secretary of State scanland uh has said
uh that's kind kind of our uh
committee's thoughts on on this uh Bill
too uh we have some concerns with how
the voters how these uaba voters are
going to get their ballots back to us um
you know which email will they send it
to I don't want it just going so say
someone in my office sent them the
request form just going to um anyone in
the office so I think maybe funnel
through the Secretary of State or
another email might be a good idea um
currently now when we get absentee
requests uh through email sometimes they
uh use you know their their phone and
they take a picture and it's way over
here and you get all this other stuff in
the background I'm concerned about that
with the B being emailed back um so
those are our main issues just the
quality of the ball we're going to get
back is you know going to be in Focus so
we going to be able to read it we're
concerned about the privacy of the voter
but again they would um um they would be
waving that option to privacy there's if
I get an email my on my computer with
the attachment I'm going to be seeing
how they vote as much as I'm trying not
to so we just have some concerns but we
do think it is um a there's some good
intent to this bill and it's a step in
the right direction but we do think it
needs some work and uh some of those
have points have been mentioned earlier
so I'd be open to any questions any
questions okay thank you
thanks our
last pres um Linda
Callaway thank you for your time really
quick um I am a veteran I served
overseas uh a long time ago um but I was
also a federal employee overseas for a
couple decades and uh I totally support
what you're doing for the military but
you have have to realize there are
federal employees and a lot of other
people who are overseas who are in just
as much danger and just as bad
conditions who deserve the same
consideration um I'll give you an
example I was overseas during the
anthrax and all of the mail was shut
down to all of the embassies the apos
and everything the only way to get
mailed back was to know somebody who
happened to be coming back to the States
so they could drop a letter in the
mailbox for you so um I just want to
make sure that you're aware of that with
what's going on overseas there are Fe
several embassies under ordered
departure um I served overseas and at
least uh for at least six years of which
it was ordered departure uh very little
access to mail so it is not as easy as
people saying I was not in a submarine
but I felt like I was in a submarine so
thank you uh please just make sure you
take care of other people who are
serving our country and other ways other
than the military thank you thank you
representing Brandon thank you um the
other federal employees that are serving
overseas are they do you know if they
are covered under uocava are they
considered uocava voters they should be
some of them are federal only vot voters
so they may only you know go in federal
um election type things that they they
vote on um uh the embassy is a good
place for people to go through and get
it when I was at an embassy um I had
access to the state department email and
there are other government systems that
can you know at least filter some of
these I understand the concern about
everybody but if you're looking at this
and you're looking at military there are
ways that the US government can help
facilitate um the people who's serving
overseas to do it more securely perhaps
than just you know sending it over a
regular email followup followup please
um when someone is serving over seas
whether it is in the military or in you
know another role stationed at an
Embassy whatever it may be DEA FBI doj
all of those people are over there do
those folks also maintain the right to
vote no as American citizens no matter
where they are stationed yes I was
overseas for 16 years and um I got to
vote as a New Hampshire resident the
whole time um my my ballot didn't get to
me once uh I don't know what happened to
it it showed up two years later when I
was in my next country over how it found
me I have no idea
but yes we do we do have the the right
to do it if you are typically you can
get your mail sent to the Embassy and
you can pick it up there if it's not to
a regular address thank yes I retain my
right to vote and that's why I became um
a moderator here um you guys made sure I
could vote no matter where I was and um
I think we should make it easier for
them but keep it secure so thank you
thank you okay thank you with that I'm
the
oh what's the online um 17 support and
21 sorry um signed in online R 17 in
support 21 opposed and zero people who
are neutral and everyone on the blue
sheet T everyone on the blue sheet spoke
so
zero okay with that I'm closing the
hearing 11:33 and turning it back to
Chairman Ros
Barry okay did you guys miss me you
don't have to lie you don't have to lie
you don't have to lie um okay we're
going to open up the public hearing on
1239 relative to reporting by political
committees are you introducing this bill
are you introducing this bill okay and
we'll recognize representative Howard um
for the purpose of introduction of the
bill and we'll indulge him in the
amendment as
well we have pink cards for this one yet
no no no no not just you but just in
general we might make lunch we'll see
all right I shouldn't have said that I
shouldn't have said that that was I'm so
sorry I am so sorry I regretted it the
moment it came out of my mouth I
apologize alrighty thank you so much for
having me today uh representative Heath
Howard representing the towns of
straford and
barington uh so hb1 1239 had a drafting
error uh that is fixed by the amendment
uh
0304 uh I'll give you all a minute to
read that uh but essentially the bill is
intended to require candidates to submit
Financial reports or test to not
spending more than $1,000 in
expenditures in a given reporting period
uh this is important because in the 2022
election 48 out of
893 state representative candidates did
not file and and we did not know if they
didn't reach the $1,000 threshold or if
they just didn't file at all whether
they didn't know or refused
to uh this would give the Attorney
General a more refined list of
candidates to examine for potential
violation and provides a legal
acknowledgement of the candidate's
responsibility to report financial
information to the state uh that pretty
much kind of covers everything and the
purpose of the bill uh and I'm open to
any questions all right questions from
the committee
oh yeah see there's no way you get away
with that all right representative
Lane
um I guess are you aware that we looked
at a lot of this over the summer in the
Omnibus campaign Finance yes so um so
the question so can I may I follow up
yes but let's avoid the word Omnibus
because I just wrote a uh I just wrote a
committee report that said we can
decrying an omnus bill so decrying it
was a uh comprehensive there we go how's
that anyway would and I think this might
have come up so would would you be
willing to work with us on the because
it might be nicer to fold that in or did
you want it to stand alone this was
actually more of a safety net uh to kind
of provide us a route forward if uh the
uh subcommittee couldn't come to an
agreement okay thank you further
questions representative weary uh
a question about inflation um it's
pretty easy to spend, dollar for signs
and door hangings would you be open to
upping the amount from 1,000 to 2,000 or
something like that um not not
necessarily because I mean even still
it's uh this is something that I think
that we may want to discuss as a
committee and my personal opinion is
that it should stay at a
thousand sounds like representative
weary will be joining the working group
on campaign Finance thank you for thank
you for your service representative
weary further questions from the
committee okay seeing none thank you
representative Howard only one person
signed up left to speak Olivia
zinc um Olivia zinc executive director
for open democracy and I'm a voter in
Franklin New Hampshire um we oppose the
bill but support the amendment um so I
know that's a very strange position to
take but um I think it's just because of
the drafting error
um I want to just talk about
transparency I think it's really
important for voters to know who spent
who's the transparency voters need to
know who's spending money um when we
looked at the 2022 campaign Finance data
nine out of the 65 candidates for state
senate didn't file campaign Finance
reports I don't know why did they not
running for Senate spend $1,000 or did
they just not file we don't know but if
you require them to at least say I
didn't meet the
threshold um or I had no
activity um then then you at least know
that they're under that threshold uh
versus the candidates that don't file
but there's often times where candidates
might file the June report but miss the
next report and then file the next
report and I was told well they probably
just didn't meet the thresold that
period but I think that they still need
to sort of check no activity during that
period um and I think that this just
gives a a needed transparency in knowing
um who's filing reports even candidates
for executive Council last time didn't
file reports and then I saw that they
filed them like nine months after the
election so um so they actually needed
to file reports but they just chose not
to file them till nine months after so I
I do think that um this checkbox would
be helpful in just providing that sort
of real time
transparency um but also help with
enforcement so you know which candidates
have uh aren't aren't complying with the
law and filing reports happy to take any
questions all right representative bone
you're up thank you so does this mean
out of the probably eight of my 11
elections that I never had any money
given to me I would still have to fill
out a form or you could just go on the
online system and check a box that says
I didn't you know
file further question representative
Bay thank you Mr
chairperson um can you clarify to me uh
because as as you said uh there you can
file and by just checking that there
there were no activities for for that
period how uh this um that how this will
help that out
the so I think no activity is different
than I didn't meet the
threshold so that's sort of two
different things so um you might have
gotten $1,000 Dollar in June spent it
but then between June and August you
might not have re met that threshold so
that's a no activity versus uh I didn't
exceed the ,000 from the start um so if
you're somebody who didn't exceed the,
you file a June report that says I
didn't exceed you file the August report
I didn't exceed and then all of a sudden
in September you have more than that and
you filed it's it's sort of once you
filed you're supposed to continue to
file that's my understanding of the
law
follow so uh is does this bill just add
another place to check correct thank you
okay further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and we
will make lunch uh there's no one else
signed up to speak in person that I'm
aware of at Le on PR cards can somebody
pass me the blue sheet uh online we had
five in favor one opposed I did read the
comment for one opposed I don't think
they were referring to this bill um but
you know they did file in against it but
their comment is uh unrelated at least
that's how I interpret it so but anyways
five to one um and we get the blue sheet
and then we get to go to lunch does
anybody know what the specials are in
the
cafeteria
oh it was uh I'm AOS repealing RSA
6646 which is not what the bill does
there's no one signed up on the blue
sheet um so with that we'll close the a
we'll close the public hearing on House
Bill 1239 and I will see you guys at 1
o'
for
okay one o'clock uh going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 1369
relative to the verification of V roles
every four years going to go ahead and
recognize our own representative Wei um
to introduce the
bill all right thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee
members um for the record my name is
Robert worry and I have the privilege of
serving in Hillsboro's County's 13th
District um which is the 10th largest
population Center in New Hampshire the
great town of Hudson
um just as a matter of the rationale for
why introducing this bill um current law
under 65438 and 65439 specifies a
verification of checklist with the
latter requiring mandatory verification
every 10 years uh however there have
been some problems with uh compliance on
this matter in the TW uh after the
20 uh no in the 2020 general election
the voter roles were calculated to have
a total of
1,100
19,23 to
voters in 2021 when the 10-year voter
list Purge was enacted under
65439 they removed approximately 21% of
the state's voter rooll list reducing
the list from the original Total over a
million ion to down to 8792714179
[Music]
% should account for transfers in and
out of New Hampshire and deaths as
factors that would affect the voting
roll counts it perhaps does not account
for firsttime
voters um and other residents voting for
the first time however the the factor uh
shouldn't really uh create that gap
between the 5.1% growth and the 21%
reduction in the number of Voters on the
voter rooll list for New Hampshire so I
think uh there is a concern that this
time period is too long um and that uh
the 10year time period is currently
codified in the RSA is too long and
therefore it needs to be reduced to a
much lower level I will also state that
um corollary to that um in after the
2020 election there was a voter
Integrity group that went around and
found uh through various forms of uh
inquiry that there had been 15,000
movers in the state and uh a thousand
examples of Deeds transfers where both
the seller and the buyer vote buyer
voted in that same
election um and an additional 800
examples were provided later to uh the
Attorney General's office and a total of
again a total of 15,000 names were
provided where uh clearly there
was um illegitimate voting going on so
um so I think if this process is at is
at least um verified on a more frequent
basis we have an opportunity to to
avoid um the the types of uh figures
that I gave before and have more
accurate voter lists and greater
Integrity in our
elections I'll take I'm happy to take
any questions if you have any questions
from the committee representative
Burnham thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for taking my question um do you
know how long the supervisor of the
checklist term is uh generally I believe
um I in my town I think I've seen three
years I I'm not entirely sure but I
think that what I've seen in my town
it but uh that's what I'm aware of
followup uh let's go to representative
bone and then we'll come
back right now 10 years they send out a
postcard saying are you're still alive
or here I mean so this is I don't know
how I couldn't read anything and how
that going to be done but you say by
newspaper a lot of towns don't have any
circulation newspapers anymore um so
it's kind of hard to say to advertise
this if there's a you know especially
you people complain about the internet I
don't have the internet you know so how
are we going to get the word out to the
people that may still exist but don't
have access
to newspapers or
Internet well thank thank you for your
question representative B I believe that
the process for removing someone from a
checklist involves a certified letter at
least that's been the practice in in the
town of Hudson so yeah um I believe that
that's how they would address it I don't
you know with respect to notifications
of Supervisors of the checklist meetings
and things like that that might have
previously appeared in newspapers I'm
not really um I'm not sure that that's
uh necessarily directly gerine to this
uh proposed uh uh bill I think I think
that is another issue that could be
addressed but I think primarily we're
trying to address the interval between
these mandatory verifications of the
checklist okay further questions repres
Burnham thank you um so I was just made
aware in my town that the um supervised
over the checklist term is six years so
um currently the voter purges 10 years
um do you see that there might be any
kind
of issue with um the long term of
checklist supervisors and only a 10 o uh
The Purge only taking place every 10
years I do I don't think there are any I
don't have any evidence of any
correlations between the length of terms
of the checklist of the supervisors and
the the what I would say is a parent
non-compliance with the 10-year voter
list Purge so I'm not sure I can I can
comment on that I think you know there
are advantages to having someone for an
extended period of time in that position
because they are familiar with the
community and perhaps someone coming in
might not be as familiar with the
community but um beyond that I I really
don't have any uh characteristics to
provide any attributes to the
correlation or causation between the
two further
questions representative wood yes thank
you for taking my question
um this morning we heard there's two
ways to change the
checklist uh one was uh if you move and
register in another uh jurisdiction and
the other one was uh a death certificate
are you aware of any others I think you
can you can um approach the supervisors
of the checklist about issues and and
ask them about that and they can
investigate that I don't have that uh
particular passage memorized but um I
think that's a possibility followup yep
followup um looking at your numbers here
21% um it seems like a a large number in
10 years if we have these two mechanisms
going on so people moving within the
state we should be seeing that if the if
they continued voters and if they're
dying we should be seeing that so 21%
even if you count all the movs moving
out of state doesn't seem like we should
come up with that many votes do you have
any clue of why this number is so high
no as as I said there's I looked at the
I tried to think of what um from a kind
of statistical point of view how how to
approach determining the validity of
that 21% reduction
in the voter Ro checklist I I thought of
looking at the population numbers over
that same time period that only has I
testified that only had a 5.1% increase
you know so it's moving the opposite
direction of the uh percentages of the
voter Ro checklist so that uh you know
that is a um you know fairly large
discrepancy um so I I don't know and and
it
certainly
is very suspect um so I think and as I
mentioned the the information that was
brought to the attorney general which
they have have said is a report is
forthcoming but but it's hard um you
know that that is an investigation
launched in
2021 detecting over 15,000 voters who
were not properly doic
iled and at least according to the
affidavit submitted to the Attorney
General's office and and so it's now
taken if if you understand that those
were presented in
2021 you know we're now in uh 2024 it's
taken an extended period of time to
properly investigate that I'm not I'm
not
um uh putting any aspersions on the
Attorney General's office you know
invest investigations take a lot of time
and so I think they're they've been
looking at I'm hoping that this report
will will you know at least to some
degree address um the concern about
having these people voting when they
shouldn't
be further
questions rter thank you Mr chair um
would you expect that this would cause
increased costs for towns and cities for
mailing advert iing anything else no I
um not unless there was a mass Exodus of
the Town um but um I think
generally um I don't think it would I in
looking
at um the factor well you know the the
very fact that they would have to do
this more frequently I believe it would
reduce the number of actions that they
would have to take and therefore I think
there's a commensurate tradeoff between
you know doing a larger list every 10
years
versus ostensibly a smaller list of
removals on a four-year cycle good
question representative
Lane you um how did you arrive at the
four-year
figure
um that's a great question I I had
discussed it with different people and
um it seemed like
like
um you I also wanted to be sensitive to
the position of the checklist of the
supervisors and I think they have um you
know regular meetings throughout the
year and
therefore
um especially during an election year
and
so I tried to I I didn't think it was
good to do it every necessarily two
years years um I did talk to some people
who would have done it every year for
that matter um I talked to some people
who wanted to do it every five years uh
kind of an off cycle with the census um
and then on on the census I picked every
four years just as being sort of a
compromise between what I thought were
various extremes and um I don't have any
evidence or or data to support that
selection other than maybe anecdotal
discussions with other
Representatives further questions from
the committee um I have one um so we
currently do this voter roll Purge every
10 years right and every 10 years we
look back four years yes so what is the
harm if we're looking back the same
period of time what is the harm of doing
it more frequently like under so
underneath current law my understanding
is someone could go without voting in
the state of New Hampshire for nine
years and be stuck on the roles until
they get to an even year to a year that
ends in zero and then they would come
off is that the that's the current law
right well in in the in the 01 year yeah
the 01 year yeah that's when it it now
is done on so the next one would would
be uh 2031 ostensibly okay so I'm trying
to accelerate that a little bit fair
enough further comment questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
representative weary thank you next up
is our own secretary
scanland
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State and I'm here in support of this
bill um I I will say that the the 10year
cycle that we're on now to verify the
checklist has been in existence for
quite some time and it certainly
predated the centralized Statewide voter
data base that we were required to put
in place when the help America vote Act
passed in 20 2 and prior to that time
many towns uh in the state kept their
checklists on their own spreadsheet
programs there were some of the smaller
towns that actually hand had handwritten
checklists and so you can understand the
reason for a 10-year cycle is it was a
big job to clean up the
list so now we are uh you know we have a
Statewide voter registration database we
are
replacing the Legacy system and hope to
go live in April or May with a brand new
database which will have a lot more
functionality it will have the national
change of address
information uh plugged into that on a uh
multiple times a year cycle uh it'll be
easier for us to transmit uh death data
from our division of Vital Records so
that the towns have better access to
that information
I would recommend a time frame of six
years and the reason that I do that is
that every there are many many many
voters in this state that only vote in a
general election when we're electing a
president and so if we purge the
checklist more frequently than that
those voters are all going to drop off
the
checklist uh before they come to vote
the next time and they'll end up having
to re-register again so um you know I
think the the cycle that we work on now
is two election Cycles or four years for
that very reason and I think it would
made make sense uh to maintain
that
the the database changes every single
day so if you print a checklist off
today it's going to be different
tomorrow and uh over over time uh the
changes are pretty dramatic so uh
whenever we did the 10-year Purge uh
just this most recent uh time I think
that there were probably 170,000 names
give or take that uh were dropped from
the list and many of those voters
re-registered for the presidential
primary and I would expect that this
fall there will be another uh uh spike
in registrations because of that but you
know that's what it takes to keep the uh
the checklist up to date I think if we
went to a six-year term those you know
those dramatic Peaks and valleys will
level out a little bit and I think that
would be a positive thing as well so I'd
be happy to answer any questions just to
clarify your your suggestion so you're
talking about every four years we would
look back every six years or every six
years we look back every four years
every six years look back
four oh sorry other questions think me
I'm writing that
down
um I guess I'll keep going um
so why wouldn't we do something like
every four years we look back five
years because that would accomplish the
same goal right five years encompasses
to two no matter what five years
Encompass is a presidential election no
matter what
um why would we go to a frequency of six
years like I would rather extend the
look back I would rather extend the look
back period than decrease the frequency
why would you want to
overlap well if it was up to me I would
do it every year so let's start off with
that I would do it every year and look
back if if I was writing this
legislation I would do it to where it
looked back every year and I would have
it look back I would do it every year
looking back five years um just to
because then you would never have a
fallof um which would actually be an
extension of what we do now it would be
longer than than what we look back now
um I was just kind of curious as the
logic of that um like how how like why
not why s why every six years looking
back four instead of every four years
looking back
five there's a uh a a tradeoff between
you know trying to address
the uh you know the number of Voters
that have dropped off the list or should
drop off the list versus the workload
that we place on the local supervisors
of the checklist and I that's probably
the most important factor yeah but you
know I'm suggesting six years as a you
know as a good interval but you know
that's an arbitrary number
yeah uh represent brenon thank you can
you explain the process um and how much
time it takes to for election officials
to conduct this purge so it can just get
an understanding of the workload uh the
time that it
takes can you help me out with that
well it takes the supervisors of a
checklist several months uh to do this
job where they they do a review of their
checklist and then those names that they
cannot confirm as voters uh because of
their because they are
inactive um then get tagged for being
dropped and there is a notice that gets
sent out that that is what is
occurring uh it's not a 30-day letter
it's it is you know you've been inactive
your name is being dropped from the list
and if you want to participate in future
elections you have to
re-register
um yeah and it does take several months
the mailings are prepared at the local
level they're paid for at the local
level but the data itself is kept and
maintained at the state level followup
please uh we had one other hand first
and we'll come back I guess they they
they're waving all you can go yes
representative Bren thank you um so if
the purge as we are calling it occurs
more frequently it sounds like there
would be a tax impact or that taxpayers
would be paying supervisors of the
checklist more money to conduct this
work is that am I understanding that
correctly that this since the
municipalities do pay for this
um this purge process which takes
several
months would we see an increase in cost
for taxpayers there may be a slight
increase in costs I think the benefit of
doing it more frequently is that that
you would reduce the number of
individuals that would be
impacted thank
you questions um you said in your
testimony it takes a long time but this
is just a data sort of people who
haven't voted in the last four years how
does that take time it's all done in the
database it is done in the database but
there is there is review there's
cleansing there's preparing the mailing
yeah it's a process okay so the data
side of it is like seconds I would
assume I would expect the data side as
long as it's clean would be very quick
would be seconds okay and then as for
the cost wouldn't the cost be the same
because we're talking about the same
number of Voters getting removed but
instead of once every 10 years it's on a
more frequently basis so wouldn't that
workload decrease because it wouldn't
just be this massive thing you're doing
every 10 years but it' be the same
number of Voters so if the cost of the
mail the postage doesn't change in the
inflation but so wouldn't the cost be
basically the same except it's less
frequent except when it happens it's not
this big large project it's just this
thing you do more frequently I I would
think that doing it more frequent more
frequently like this bill suggests would
lower the cost for each time that it was
done I haven't done enough of an
analysis to say that it would just be a
level cost fair enough thank you any
other questions representative Ward
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr scanland
um secretary could you explain a little
bit of how the national change of
address match system whatever it's
called precisely
might uh work on this bill so there are
my understanding is that there are
third-party vendors that have been
approved by the United States Postal
Service that will collect all the
information from the postal records
about individuals that have moved and
filed with a post office that they have
permanently changed their address and
that that information is available uh at
certain intervals over the course of a
year and uh there's a subscription cost
to obtaining that information but uh
once that Arrangement has been made that
information is uh put into the
transferred into the database so so that
that information is available then for
supervisors of the checklist to go
through and clean up their
records follow up one follow up yep so
do we not subscribe to this already I
thought they re at least one one I
believe we do with the new database
though I think we're going to have a
better format for transferring that data
yeah thank you all right further
questions see none all right thank you
secretary
scanland um next up is Al Brandon
um I'm going to withdraw I just put bill
I put it on paper I should have done
that thank you no worries um all
right hold
on uh all right next up then will be um
McKenzie St
Germain good afternoon members of the
committee um good to see you all all
again my name is Mackenzie St Germain
I'm the campaign director for the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights um
which is a nonpartisan Coalition uh
devoted to expanding and protecting
voter access and it's a project of
America votes New Hampshire um we are
opposing uh HB 1369 today we'll say we
do believe in cleaner checklists and the
efforts that are needed to make our
checklist cleaner in New Hampshire
however there are ways to do that Beyond
uh expanding the number of times we
remove folks who are not voting and
maybe miss one presidential election um
other ways I know secretary just
mentioned the national change of address
data that is a better way to capture
people who are moving and no longer live
um where they formerly registered as
opposed to folks who again might have
missed one presidential election know
the election information portal is also
moving through the legislature it's
another way for folks to update their
addresses when they move keeping those
lists cleaner and focusing on address as
opposed to missing an election and then
being unknowingly move removed from a
list um and I believe this committee
will also be hearing later uh in the
session about the electronic
registration information center um which
will track folks if they move out of
state are no longer eligible to vote in
New Hampshire um and those are all ways
that we would support in terms of
keeping our checklist cleaner more
updated and capturing folks when they
are no longer uh able to vote because
they've moved out of where they formerly
domiciled as opposed to removing folks
more frequently just because of lack of
voting um and not necessarily because we
have the information that they are no
longer eligible to vote I'm not an
expert on the checklist process was
trying to keep track the years and
thinking what presidential election is
what but if there are questions uh I can
try to answer them questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you last up is Daniel
Healey
represent AR can you go and grab that
blue sheet for
me hi Dan hilly uh NAA city clerk uh
representing New Hampshire City and town
clerk's
Association uh we are in support of uh
this legislation we do agree with uh
going down from the 10 years to the four
years uh to keep the voter lists as
accurate as possible uh there are some
other things that occur when you know
you get a certain amount of Voters
removed we're required to set up um a
specific amount of voting booths per
voter so if the lists aren't accurate we
might need 60 more voting booths to
support the the what's on our checklist
so there are some things that from our
end tie into this this voter checklist
being the most accurate as possible um I
was in another Community for the last
Purge and we purged about 6,000 voters
that's a lot of work for the supervisor
of the checklist to be to be doing to be
mailing those out and that 6,000 people
uh would amount to in that election
prior would have been 60 less voting
boosts that needed to be set up so there
are some tie-ins to to those sorts of
things we do uh the national change of
address we do the 30-day letters if
we're notified someone has moved moved
out um we match uh death records we do
all that stuff but I think this is
another layer this is another step that
helps us get to that goal of keeping the
voter list as accurate as possible um
and if someone's not voting with in a
four-year time frame I mean I think
that's long enough that they should
probably should be removed at that point
they have the option New Hampshire has
same day voter registration they can
come to the polls they can re-register
so we we do have all those options for
the voters um I do see some of the other
the the arguments on the other side but
uh New Hampshire with that same day
registration we're not disenfranchising
anyone and we're keeping the voter lists
um as accurate as possible for that that
moment in time so I'd be open to any
questions questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you um in
in that instance in in just referencing
the same day voter registration if we do
these purges more often
wouldn't that increase the amount of
same potentially increase the same day
voter registrations and thus create more
work for the supervisors of the
checklist on an already busy day on
Election Day it it has the potential to
increase the same day registrations I
think um a good check is you know the
four years where there's a presidential
election in November I think um that's
the election we have our highest turnout
so if someone's not
say voting in that election I don't know
how often they they will be um
participating in elections so there
could be some additional same day
registrations there's could be some
people that we remove that will then end
up registering again I don't see it
being a real high amount um we have a
lot of people that vote in every
election we have some people that only
vote you know the every four years but
with the same day registration they have
that option I don't think it's going to
you know bog down the line
uh for those people followup please we
got to go over to represent Burnham
first unless she wants to yield I can
yield for her followup that's
fine thank you
um
oh all right back to representative
bernon thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question you had mentioned
that there were about 6,000 Purge in the
last um 10e cycle there I was just
wondering if it's uh would be helpful to
know how you would set up for voting day
would that also help reduce the cost of
uh printing ballots and having those
available for election so those numbers
would tie in uh in state and federal
elections the secretary of state
provides the municipalities with the
amount of ballots and they look at uh
the number of registered voters and they
obviously do a percentage higher than
that uh figuring in for uh any same day
registrations but they use the numbers
that are in the election system to kind
of calculate how many ballots um they
should be producing for us in in the
municipal election I'm looking at the
same thing how many uh registered voters
do we have in each Ward so I know how
many ballots to order so if the numbers
are inflated for you know um people that
were reg you know registered at one
point that aren't actually going to vote
or have moved then we have to more order
more ballots and it costs more money so
that it does tie into a few of these
things
followup um I'm not sure if this
pertains to you but we were talking
about um additional costs of um possibly
purging on a more frequent basis um are
you aware if the checklist supervisors
that are elected are being paid by hour
or is it just like a stip in so it
varies by uh what the municipality wants
to do some are hourly some uh get a
stipended um in a city clerk's office uh
my staff would be the ones managing uh
the
day-to-day uh of of removing the voters
and then it would go to the board of
registrants for approval so it really
depends on what the municipality is
structured some pay their registrars $10
some get a few hundred stien per month
it's it it varies across the state it's
not uh
uniform okay any uh representative PR
O'Brien thank
you uh you talked about a purge of 6,000
voters um I think that was Derry that
was yeah were were there any problems in
the election after that with uh
registering people to vote if they had
been inadvertently removed uh and still
lived in town for example just didn't
vote for a long time and
with the supervisors of the checklist
were there any problems at the next um
election I don't believe in the uh
following elections that there are any
major issues sometimes you would have
the occasional person that would you
either request an absentee ball or show
up at the polling location and say that
they had registered prior and then when
it was explained to them the process and
what had occurred uh they seemed okay
with that then they would re-register I
don't recall an overwhelming um amount
of Voters or um a ton of complaints
regarding it but there were probably you
know there were some that were Purge
that then ended up coming back and
re-registering representative Brennan
thank you would the clerks Association
be okay with the secretary's
recommendation of an amendment to six
years or do you hold firm at
four
I believe the Secretary of State's
office made some some good points uh
without speaking with our committee um
directly I I don't know if I could fully
answer that I mean I
think our thoughts on the initial bill
was that it was a good a good bill um
four years does seem reasonable but I
don't want to speak for the entire
committee without um without discussing
it with them but I I think we were
pretty pretty satisfied with the four
years good thank
you pres
Lane thank you and thanks for taking my
question um a lot of your answers have
been conditioned on the fact that same
day registration exists and it's pretty
routine and can be handled what if that
did not
exist I if there was no same day
registration I think a lot of the other
laws would need to be looked at to
provide some opportunity for these
voters
so with the current law as it is I I
think the four years is you know is a
good time frame for those okay thank you
further questions all right seeing none
thank you thank you uh representative
where you want back up you want more uh
while you're up there so I did some
quick math on the there's going to be a
surge of people same day registering so
after the
2021 Purge there was a 4% same day
registration before for The Purge there
was a 9% same registration now midly
this is two elections uh correlation is
not causation um but on Face Value the
argument is moot um representative weing
yes um the discussion has reminded me of
the rationale for the four years and the
four-year look back it's cycled so that
so I think everyone knows that we get
much greater turnout during the
presidential elections every four years
comparatively lower um on other
intervals um this would look back um
prior to the year prior to the next
presidential election it looks back four
years and so would include the
previous presidential election and so
you have the best chance and opportunity
of capturing the greatest voter turnout
that occurred in that community in that
thing I I do not think that the six-year
cycle would accomplish that so um I W
during the discussion I was reminded of
the rationale for that so I wanted to um
add that to the
testimony okay all right um thank you I
think that's it um uh okay uh in person
there were three people signed up to
speak uh sorry there was ah five people
signed up who didn't speak three support
to opposed online little lopsided uh it
was 17 support 70 oppose and one neutral
I would love to meet the neutral person
um with that going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 1369 to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 1442 FN
relative to the penalties for failures
for election officers to adhere to
election law uh and I believe
representative kushman are you
introducing
yes welcome to election law
representative kushman thank you thank
you Mr chairman and thank you members of
the committee for the record my name is
Leah kushman I represent the town of
wear I am introducing this bill on
behalf of the sponsor as she had um some
urgent personal business to attend to
and asked me to do that for her uh that
being said I may not be able to answer
any technical questions but I'll do my
best uh the bill before you HB
1442 adds one new section J to RSA 65 9
colon
34 that includes election
officers um under the penalties for
voter fraud and for being uh liable for
those penalties uh for any violation of
any election law in any
election and the reason for this bill um
it's in the spirit of raising voter
confidence as we know um many voters are
feeling
disenfranchised by uh what they perceive
to be some uh deficiencies in the voting
system in our election system in New
Hampshire so amending and clarifying RSA
3 uh 659 colon 34 to include them as
responsible parties uh for voter
registration authentication is very
important um election officers those
processing some uh same day voter
registrations supervisors of the
checklists election moderators Etc will
be required to be held to the same legal
standard as those presenting as
qualified voters voters will be assured
that the Personnel entrusted to oversee
all elections in their municipalities
are performing their duties with
integrity and in accordance with all
applicable election statutes and voters
will know that there are uniform
penalties for knowingly violating
election laws therefore removing the
veil of Suspicion and skep
iism that some voters currently focus on
the hardworking election officials by
implementing this amended language we
will continue to demonstrate to the
voters that New Hampshire takes election
integrity and security
seriously and I'd ask the committee to
support uh the bill as introduced and
I'll try to answer any questions okay
questions from the
committee seeing representative
wearing um
the yeah
sorry I know that's well I got short
arms please um so uh thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um so
any election law how
how broad in scope is that is that you
know if if they forget to
post um if the moderator forgets to post
a list um
exactly the way the law prescribes for
example would that be considered a
violation I'm I'm just concerned that it
might be too broad um comments on that
thank you for the question I was just
going to pull up the statute to see what
it's covering
um it looks like it's called penalties
for voter
fraud um
yeah that's what I'm looking for
5934 you're right it's wrongful voting
penalties for voter fraud is the
section and if you don't mind I'll just
read a couple of the other things under
that section for the committee um a
person is subject to a civil penalty not
to exceed $5,000 if such person and then
there's you know some some violations
they could make when registering to vote
if they vote more than once um if
there's fraud in their um voter
registration if they apply for a ballot
in the name of others uh apply for a
ballot in their own name after they
voted already if they voted for an
office or measure at an election they're
not qualified to vote at gives a false
name or
answer um or presents falsified proof of
identity so it seems that it falls under
specifically um managing who is eligible
to vote and who is not
is how I read
it
followup so uh do
you think the sponsor and co-sponsors
might be amendable to something akin to
performs as an election officer and any
election and facilitates wrongful voting
and voter fraud just to narrow that the
scope of it so that the enforcement is
not directed for you know equivalent
misdemeanors if you will but but is
really addressing the felonies again
analogy
wise to me that sounds reasonable um I
can't speak for the co-sponsor but she's
reasonable in my
experience representative Raptor thank
you Mr chair I don't know why the
statement got me in your in your
testimony you said uh knowingly violates
a law but this as proposed doesn't have
that it just says and violates
um would it be reasonable to include
knowingly prior to
that thank you for the question um I
think it would be probably reasonable
however all of the election officials
are trained so they do receive the laws
they know what they're supposed to do um
so I think it would be if it came to a
jury and they were adjudicating and they
were fact finding on this if they were
to try to say that they didn't know and
they were trained election officials
even if the statute said knowingly I see
it as they wouldn't really be able to
get out of they wouldn't be able to say
they didn't know but that's that's how I
read
it further questions seeing none thank
you she's waving she's waving off all
right thank you representative kushman
um next up is McKenzie St Germaine we
also did get reloaded on pink cards
thank you chair Vice chairman B um and
here they come that's her last book she
said hello again uh members of the
committee again I'm McKenzie St Germaine
with the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights and America votes New
Hampshire um here today to oppose House
Bill
1442 you know we know and heard in front
of this committee many times that New
Hampshire elections are safe secure and
that is in large part to the work of our
election officials uh in state
especially because we have a very
decentralized system our towns and
cities are really run and those
elections are run by the election
officials they are not in it for the
glamour or clout or paycheck that they
get from those roles they're in those
roles for the public service um and
being able to carry out democracy at the
most local level in state and this takes
thousands of election officials um
volunteers I know there were certain
pulling places with over 100 volunte or
cities over 100 unteers running our
elections um and these folks are
increasingly under a microscope uh
there's some national surveys of
election officials um in April of
2023 research conducted by the Brennan
Center for justice said nearly three in
four election officials reported that
they felt threats against them had
increased in recent years and 30%
surveyed uh reported that they had been
personally abused harassed or threatened
due to their role um thankfully in in
New Hampshire we have not seen quite the
same level of resignation and turnovers
from election officials however if we
were to see this bill become law um and
election officials operating in an
environment where any mistake they made
could land them with a voter fraud
charge I think that would put us at risk
for those similar kind of Trends and um
even more resignations folks not being
willing to do Public Service in order to
carry out our democracy uh for risk of
being hit with voter fraud charges uh
would like to remind this committee as
well that currently at least the last
election the election procedure manual
was over 400 pages so although our
election officials are trained this bill
does not you know lay out that it would
have to be some sort of a intentional
you know charge and sort of intentional
mistake um is any of those things as the
law is written in or the bill is written
in those 400 plus pages of procedures um
and generally you know if our election
volunteers and officials who want to
serve their communities are legally
responsible for mistakes I think again
we could see there will not be willing
to serve in those very important roles
that are the backbone of our New
Hampshire elections so um with that we
ask that you uh recommend in expedient
to legislate on hp1
1442 and I happy to answer questions
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you thank you um next up is
Michael last name man uh excuse me Mr
chairman uh I just have a quick
parliamentary inquiry about the bill uh
so under RSA 654 34 there's no penalty
outlined in the
RSA and yeah this is uh this is say
something you bring up in exec okay yeah
you can't a parliamentary inquiry is not
used to discuss the bill a parliamentary
inquiry is used to discuss actions of
the chair I had I just wanted to know if
uh just for some clarification on that
yeah you have now that that is totally
something that you can ask any of the
people testifying that's a totally fair
question just not me just all right
we'll try again Michael um how your last
name I have trouble reading
itan oh
Bean
gotta hit that hit that button is that
working I come in support of
1442 um I got really deeply involved in
elections during the District 24 recount
and um saw things that made my head
spin uh much of it was documented
through the require through um request
of 91a but as recently as January 23rd I
I have witnessed
uh election law
violation and it's ongoing and it's not
being corrected the Attorney General's
office really has its hands tied unless
the legislature imposes an opportunity
to to fine and and stop some of what is
taking place uh
without the uh house and the Senate
acting and
imposing some kind of fines
this is never ever going to resolve
itself so um we've witnessed rsas being
violated over and over again I can give
you very specific examples I have a a
book here full of it and as I said I
witnessed it again on January 23rd uh
meeting requirements of rsas for testing
ballots for example you're required to
put ballots through a machine face up
forward and backward face down forward
and backward the ballot doesn't go
through through I see the ballot turned
and it gets sent through the same way it
was sent previously does nothing to
validate the test I have uh been to the
Attorney General's office with our uh
RSA required activity logs to be filled
out completely which weren't they aren't
signed they aren't witnessed twice
this's very little documentation there
are Cod numbers missing on the activity
files the SEC uh attorne General did an
investigation and the next time I walked
into my town
hall uh my my Town's folk met me and
said yep we got our slap on the wrist
thank you very much for that and life
goes on so unless we do something about
it via penalty it's it it's not going to
get corrected there's a lot of human
nature out there if you don't have a a a
policeman enforcing a speed limit then
people tend to speed if he out there
they tend to slow down we need to do
something there's nothing more important
than our elections and I heard uh
previous testimony that our elections
are uh fair safe and secure and there is
no evidence of that and there's never
been an investigation there was a
confidence committee established but
there was never an investigation if you
investigate and you see what's wrong
then something has to be done about it
this went before the ballot law
commission they referred it to the
Attorney General's office we've not
heard back from them yet there has been
no investigation to the best of my
knowledge yet and this you're open to
seeing anything you'd like to see in
here it's all factual it's a complete
breakdown of seven towns and it's a
complete breakdown of election law from
Seven towns so please feel free to reach
out ask if you want any additional
information I'd be glad to provide it I
support this bill and I think that we
absolutely have to have them thank you
okay questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Mr Bean
uh next up Tom Murray or
mass oh Murray sir Murray okay
sorry I I I don't criticize anybody's
handwriting because mine is the worst
M's atrocious I apologize it's not
personal I promise you I don't take it
sir personally um thank you members of
the committee um ladies and gentlemen um
today I stand before you to advocate for
the necessity of stringent
accountability measures for election
officials who violate election laws the
Integrity of our electoral process is
the Bedrock of our constitutional
republic ensuring that every Citizen's
voice is heard and ballots counted
accurately however this foundational
principle is at risk for those entrusted
to uphold it and they are not held to
the higher standards of conduct and
responsibility the the proposed
amendment to RSA 634 specifically
subsection J is a critical step in
reinforcing the sanctity of our
elections IT addresses a gap in our
current legislation by explicitly
holding election officials accountable
for any breach of election laws this
provision is not merely punitive but it
serves as a deterrent against potential
misconduct and it ensures a fair
transparent and trustworthy electoral
process election officials wield
significant influence over the
administration of our elections from
voter registration to Counting of
ballots their actions can affect the
outcome of Elections as we clearly saw
in windham's 2020 general election and
yet again in windham's 2022 primary
election deteriorating the very fabric
of our constitutional republic I brought
for with me today I'm probably failed to
mention I'm a resident of Windham and
know we played a significant role in the
h B I'm sorry the S sp43 forensic audit
bill that passed unanimously and what I
brought with me here today for your
review and I hope that each and every
one of you take the time to review
review both of these documents these are
both joint Letters From The Joint
Secretary of State's office and the
Attorney General's office in 2020
outlining over 130 violations of
election
law subsequent to the next federal
election we had yet another 33
violations of election law and by the
way that was under the watchful eye of a
appointed monitor pursuant to RSA
677 and just recently two weeks ago
Aaron
Hennessy had the benefit of seeing
firsthand the incompetence of our
election monitor Peter moderator excuse
me our election moderator Peter Griffin
and our assistant moderators both Betty
Dunn and gayen Sterns we went till 1:30
in the morning County 4,700 ballots and
approximately 900 in the devcraft
primary completely
unacceptable the tapes were printed all
the absentee ballots were processed all
the hand count writings were done by
9:24 we didn't finish till 1:30 in the
morning and yet
again inaccurate
results were gone ahead and published 15
minutes later they had to go ahead and
correct
those
so when these individuals violate
election laws whether through negligence
or through intentional misconduct it
undermines public confidence in the
electoral system it creates a Shadow of
Doubt over the legitimacy of election
outcomes which can lead to widespread
decline in voter confidence and the
erosion of trust in governmental
institutions accountability
accountability measures such as the one
proposed are essential for several
reasons
deterrence clearly defined penalties act
as a deterrent to potential violators
knowing the consequences of their
actions election officials are more
likely to adhere strictly to the law
Integrity by holding election officials
accountable we reinforced the Integrity
of the electoral process it sends a
clear message that the system is robust
with checks and balances in place to
prevent and address any form of
misconduct Trust public trust in the
electoral process is a vital is vital
for the functioning of our
constitutional republic when citizens
believe the elections are conducted
fairly and lawfully their trust in the
electoral process and its outcomes is
strengthened
President establishing clear penalties
for violation such a legal precedent
that can guide the conduct of election
officials into future elections it
ensures consistency and fairness in the
application of Law and in Justice For
Those like
myself who have been affected by
violations of election law knowing that
there are mechanisms in place to hold
offenders accountable provides a sense
of justice enclosure it affirms that no
one is above the law not even those who
administer it in conclusion the
amendment to RSA
65934 with the inclusion of subsection J
is a necessary me measure to safeguard
the Integrity of our elections it Ur the
violation of of election officials are
held accountable for their actions
thereby protecting the Cornerstone of
our constitutional republic I urge you
to support this amendment and affirm our
Collective commitment to Fair
transparent and trustworthy electoral
process thank
you okay uh will you taking questions
from the committee absolutely all right
questions from the committee
representative Lane thank you um and
thanks for taking my question the report
that you indicated that had a lot of and
I forgot the number that you indicated
had a lot of different violations
recently is that something that you're
submitting to us as okay yes ma'am and
follow up yeah and how many of those
violations would you call what and I'm
sorry I'm a lawyer but would you call
material or substantive and I think it
gets to representative weary's question
which is are these
any violations like the the cone is not
set up properly or they don't have the
right distance for people to stand or
are we talking
active Mis beasant or mouth beasant
thank you for that question that's a
great question um if I could just let me
cite just a couple things from this
joint letter from the Secretary of State
and the attorney general windham's
election nights results were not just
and precise they were fundamentally
flawed
quote other errors such as only six test
ballots instead of 50 ignored legal
obligations and are of continuing
concern as they are indicative of an
election that was not executed to the
standard of law or the expectation of
Voters this goes on to outline over 130
violations some more significant than
others nevertheless we had the largest
numerical discrepancy in state voting
history here in
Windham and it wasn't corrected it
continues to this
day representative Hamlet thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question were were
these violations from the most recent
election to January 23rd the January
23rd the uh report hasn't been issued
yet by uh uh deputy secretary of state
Aaron Hennessy so um I can tell you that
there were concerns whether there was
violations I've yet to get any of the uh
moderator's worksheets the moderator
certificate the vote tallies the um the
um the checklist I have I have yet to do
that and I I don't believe the Secretary
of State's office has weighed in on that
as of yet but 2022 this just came out on
January 4th 2024 followup followup so so
these violations were from which
election the two I reference here in
these letters this was this first letter
is dated January 7th of 2022 this
represents the general election of 2020
this letter here is dated January 4th of
2024 this represents the September 13th
Primary in 2022 okay thank
you representative
wearing uh so in our discussion with the
previous speaker we talked about
changing the violates any election law
to facilitates wrong
uh voting or Andor voter fraud does that
narrow the scope too much for the
concerns that you've presented in your
letters I'm not objective to narrowing a
scope however it would have to be
narrowed with a point of accountability
that prevents election officials from
continuing to operate in the manner in
which they're doing so just so the
committee is
clear these violations we had a very
significant audit $770,000 was spent by
the state that detailed this you would
think that it would be reasonable to
expect that these violations weren't
made yet
again I heard you mention Mr chair folds
and ballots believe it or not in 2022
that was is one of the 33 violations
that they actually committed again and
what happens was these reports come from
the attorney general and the Secretary
of State's office however they do not
have any
means that the legislature has given
them to go ahead and hold these
individuals accountable so yet here we
are today and we just had another
election with the same individuals
responsible for this malfeasance
continuing to go ahead and conduct
elections and not doing it pursuant to
the
law okay all right I'm going to help
here a little bit um because we've asked
the same question three different ways
all right so the section that it's going
in establishes a $5,000 fine to the
person what the sponsor is doing is they
are adding a clause to the very end of
the list of things that are referenced
saying if the person is an election
officer and they violate any election
law so the reason you're seeing the
stuff there above there about
registering to vote is cuz that's what
the title is and what they're doing is
they're moving that Ora statement from
section 8 to section I and then adding a
j station so to kind of clear things up
it's targeted at election officers who
violate the election law and it's a fine
up to $5,000 so that's what we're
talking about all right I hope that
helped or didn't make it worse or who
knows probably made it worse
representative Brennan thank you
um I'm wondering
if you know if the election officer
reference in this
bill
is an elected election officer or is it
a volunteer or Does it include every
single person that works at an election
because our elections are largely run by
volunteers and I have some concerns
because they are sworn in as election
officers on Election Day that this would
be targeting volunteers and lead
to fewer volunteers and less efficient
elections uh because we would not be
able to recruit people who might worry
that they are going to be fined $5,000
and I'm wondering if you if you
understand it like that is it just
electeds or volunteers or all of the
above yeah thank you for that question
I'm acutely aware of that and that
actually has crossed my mind and given
me pause
however it doesn't solve the problem
without the teeth and the
bill it's not just our moderator it's
our town clerk it's our
selectman it's also volunteers people
that volunteer and get sworn in as
assistant moderators those individuals
are actually culpable in guilty for
these
violations the problem is is how do
I get redress of my grievance because I
haven't had a free and fair election in
four elections three Federal
elections and the only thing I feel is I
I can do at this point in time is to
file
litigation which as a residents of wind
him I shouldn't be forced to do that
because of the competence of these
election
officials who fly in the face of the
election law because they're not held to
any accountability of it so they
continue to this day to make the same
mistakes over and over and I'm not
saying they're doing it in a malicious
way but nonetheless the malfeasance is
occurring further questions
representative P Brien thank you
sir usually
when okay usually when these things
happen the redress of grievances would
be other people are
elected so what you bring up I think is
really um singular in what we hear I we
don't hear about other towns with these
problems uh very often and to the level
that you're discussing so since the
first letter has come out where you say
there's 100 or more uh 130 I think I
remember I I read that one uh when it
came out has there been an election and
have new people been elected or are they
the same people that's a great question
in fact I actually volunteered myself to
run for moderator I was unsuccessful in
my bid to do so and that's unfortunate
and they continue but nonetheless that
doesn't doesn't address the violations
of part one article 11 and and part two
article 32 in my constitutional
guaranteed rights to a free and fair
election that's still being violated to
this
day so I understand the question is the
remedy at The Ballot Box I would submit
to you that this letter dated January
4th 2024 speaks to the opposite that it
continues and I shouldn't have to run
for office to guarantee those rights
that are afforded to
me further questions from the
committee oh oh wow okay representative
wood thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question are you aware of
other towns with similar
problems um could you be more specific
well it seems like uh there was a
question asked that winam seems to have
a particular problem are you aware of uh
similar towns that would benefit from
this type of uh legislation I am a well
I am aware of other cities and towns in
the state that that have similar
violations of election law that are
detailed in the Windom joint complaints
yes sir I am did I follow up follow up
do they have similar uh backing of
information like you have there
specifics it sound sounds to me I
haven't seen you let me just finish the
so you know what I'm trying to ask you
sorry uh sorry for interrupting you uh I
haven't seen those the paperwork you
have there but it sounds like there's
spec very specific evidence
what I would call evidence 130 okay are
youare are you aware of other towns
having similar type of evidence I am I
am aware that there are some cities and
towns that have similar violations of
election law that are detailed in both
letters from the Secretary of State and
Attorney General's office I am okay
thank you you're welcome further
questions representative Prim O'Brien
thank
you to get to what representative wood
was asking are you familiar with them
being a of the same amount the same
number I I remember in my community we
had something it was like five or six
violations and I was stunned about that
back then but now it's just a whole new
ball game to me that's what it seems
like are you familiar with any Town
coming close to those numbers you're
talking about in Windham
marac okay um marac was probably one of
the most egregious in the 2020 election
um when we talked about F that's in
ballots Windam was around 99.6%
marac was over
22% so you had a significant effect
however it's important to note that
house bill 1163 remedied part of the fix
for that um however the U what's been
coined the Phantom vote that's still um
an issue to this
day okay so here's what we're going to
do uh we're going to pause this we're
going to recess this uh house bill 14 um
House Bill
1442 um because we are over time and the
sponsor of House Bill
1596 oh actually hold on that's you I
I'm more represent
McGuire are you currently in a committee
no okay all right never mind we're gonna
keep
going you thank you so much uh and thank
you for taking my question uh so th this
this bill uh places the penalty uh
section J in RSA
65934 uh which States uh at the top of
uh section one a person is subject to
civil penalty a a civil penalty not to
exceed
$5,000 if such person and then it would
suggest part J uh is there anything
preventing somebody uh from serving as
an election official again because this
is only listed under the Civil penalty
part of the
statute I'm sorry can you rephrase the
last part of your question uh
so essent ially uh because part J is
being placed under part one of RSA
65934 which states a person is subject
to a civil penalty not to exceed $5,000
if such person would uh be subject to
performing as an election officer in any
election and violates any election law
that is uh that's from my interpretation
states that they would be subject to the
$5,000 up to a $5,000 Cil penalty is
there anything preventing an election
officer uh from serving again if this is
only a civil
penalty I don't think it prevents um
someone from serving again however I
think it deters someone from serving if
they're going to continue to make
violations as is the case in the town of
wiim that perhaps um significant
penalties were levied on these
individuals after clear findings were
made and it's important to note too to
the committee these are official
findings by the Attorney General's
office they're not just my opinion so um
yeah I would hope that it would in in
fact I think it's really notable to
mention that one of the individuals
that's actually responsible for many of
these violations happens to be running
for moderator this election
cycle okay thank you we're going to let
Mr Murray go um uh where should I give
you test give that to representative
anenberg he
Dan hilly city clerk NASA um
representing New Hampshire City and town
clerk's
Association So based off of what the
previous speaker said I just want to
provide some clarification on this bill
this bill is uh dealing with election
officers so there was a Bill last year
that passed that deals with election
officials so the election officials are
the elected members the clerk the
moderator the
Selectmen there is already a bill that
establishes penalties if they violate
any election laws and there should be a
bill for that we are the ones that are
dealing with this uh daily basis we know
the procedure manual we know the
election laws we train these people
for you know maybe it's a three-hour
session the week prior a few weeks prior
to the election the state provides
election training for anyone that wants
uh to go but these people are doing it
on a limited basis and I think to have
them have a you know a pretty
significant
violation um if they make a mistake I
mean that's a pretty big deal there was
talk about putting the word knowingly in
and I think we'd be amendable to that so
performs as an election officer in any
election and know only violates any
election law you know if someone is
blatantly uh they they their goal is to
become an election um officer and to get
up you know day of the election and
violate all these election laws and
they're doing it you know on purpose
that's there's a difference there but if
you put that word knowingly I think you
know we could get behind that if they're
knowingly violating
um known laws um but I don't think that
the uh volunteer in some cases their
volunteers that signs up to work that
day should be faced with the same
penalties that our election officials
that are you know trained and signed up
and um or elected to these positions
should be facing and I'd like to add as
president of the uh Clerk's Association
some of these issues that happened in
Windam from from 2020 they've been
addressed with s SP uh uh
43 um you're going back a few years now
uh the Windom officials aren't here to
defend themselves on those statements
but I think at this time it's kind of
inappropriate to be going back that many
years with that many accusations against
those officials uh without them here to
defend themselves and this bill doesn't
talk about uh election officials it's
election officers
so I'd be open to any
questions questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you am I
correct in understanding your testimony
that your interpretation of this bill
where it refers to election officer
would include volunteers and not
just elected election officials I
believe that's what this bill um is
doing it's now adding the the volunteers
the people that just sign up for that
day their previous bill regarding
election officials um covers you know
the moderators clerks but this bill I
think specifically is tying in those
people that just are you know the
onetime workers of that day thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you Mr Healey uh next
up it last up is Al
brandano like a bad Penny huh just keep
showing up
uh thank you I'm Al brand Deno from
Kensington I speak in support of uh hb1
1442 um one of my uh someone I respect
really a lot in this room and and is uh
secretary
scandin um really because in
2022 he took a really major major
challenge Challenge and voted confidence
voted confidence was falling off the
cliff and I'm sure against a lot of
political pressure he was able to stand
up and gave the citizens a place to be
heard it was around the state when all
around the state I was part of that and
testified there and one of the biggest
things that Secretary State when he
comes and he speaks is always about
we're here for voter
confidence um and I want it it's hard
for
I'm one of the volunteers that's been
part of a lot of these audits not just
me but there's hundreds of people like
me that have put in thousands of hours
of time because we too want safe and
secure elections and honest elections
you want everyone wants that but we've
been Vol volunteering to do that so I
want to point out something here in the
election procedure manual you realize
that to hold anybody accountable this
whole manual 90% of this is
procedures it's not accountable by law
only a very small percentage about 10%
that's regulated through the RSA gives
you the Authority for to to make a
penalty I want to read this part to you
for just a second it's a subar paragraph
4 the election procedure manual was a
resource and learning learning tool the
manual was not a substitute for the
relevant statutes or legal advice Court
decisions in and changes to the statutes
made between printings and the manual
may change election law whenever
uncertainty exists as to the what action
to take we will make our best effort to
assist you and you should consult your
local legal
attorney this in this manual for the
people who do the work there is no
there's no violation for
them we want to hold the people that
make the decisions the moderators the
town clerks people who are in Authority
accountable so if you think about it um
I I happened in my town in Kensington um
discovered that the activity logs for
the machines the data the data cards and
the activity logs that record by a you
know we signed two signatures and the
maintenance person that's an affidavit
we found that a bunch of them 40% were
not accurate or not signed we went to
the Department of Justice myself and and
my
um at the Department of Justice um we
have three sworn affidavits let me read
this quick during the meeting Mike Bean
asked the question of Mr Madison and
Tracy who is ultimately responsible
party for the purchase maintenance
programming security chain of custody
and operational use of voting machines
and elections Mr Madison responded the
selectman Mr Bean asked again for a
clarification Mr Madison again the
selectman so I'm trying to we're all
trying to find out everyone is doing
this we losing Confidence from the
regular people who show up and do the
work we need to have some type of
accountability just a second
here
yeah um Senate District 24 I was part of
the recount
uh it was lug guard jula's race
violations 174 they're here and they're
as egregious as um chain of custody no
chain of custody on the boxes in fact
you're going to hear later on about
boxes the boxes were a lot of them were
were didn't have the proper tape on them
or the tape was missing or they weren't
documented all that's here these are not
insignificant not you know having the
line big enough and it was all went to
the U ballot law commission and the
ballot law commission recommended it to
the Department of Justice you know
what's happened nothing
nothing
so one of the questions that the ballot
law commission asked was would the
election have been affected due to these
many
violations the loyer for Lugar julo his
name is uh attorney McDonald stated how
can you say it would be with this many
operational violations you can't attest
to it nor can we this is the problem
when we have procedural errors we have
to look at them as they add up right and
it takes away voter confidence that's
what we're here
for and last um for all of us um if you
don't have anyone to hold accountable
then we basically have have tyranny so
thank you questions from the committee
seeing none n I'm sorry thank thank you
um representative Hammer thank you just
a question have you ever worked in an
election uh I have been a Moder not a
moderator a poll Watcher and a poll
challenger but I've never worked in the
elections thank you further questions
seeing none thank you um can you grab
that blue sheet um online there were 13
in support 82 opposed zero neutral with
that we're going to get the is anything
on the blue
sheet
all right okay chairman Barry can you
just repeat those online numbers again
uh yes the tough ones uh 13 to
82 uh spoke spoke spoke yes yes okay so
there were two people signed up that
didn't speak one four and one against
with that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 1442 and
immediately open up the house public
hearing on House Bill
1596 requiring a disclosure of deceptive
artificial intelligence usage in
political
advertising um and recognize
representative Brennan uh to introduce
the
Bill thank you Mr
chair
thank you I am state representative
Angela Brennan from Bo representing
meramac District 9 Bo and Hopkinton I am
proud to introduce HB
1596 a bipartisan Bill to begin to
address the use of artificial
intelligence as it relates to
elections I'd first like to thank Mr
chairman Barry and vice chairman B for
co-spon sponsoring this bill as well as
all the other co-sponsors it is
appreciated not only by me but Granite
Staters when we are able to come
together on Common Sense legislation
like this
bill 2024 is the first election year
where artificial intelligence seems to
be accessible at everyone's fingertips
indeed what once cost thousands of
dollars can now be done in a couple of
minutes using an iPhone app for Next
nothing deceptive synthetic media
manipulates images audio and video to
trick the viewer or listener and depicts
something that did not actually occur in
real life in an age of rapidly advancing
technology and an ever increasing rise
in disinformation the 2024 election is a
perfect storm ripe for dirty tricks let
me State emphatically the dissemination
a of disinformation is detrimental to
our democracy and we must do something
about it hb1 1596 requires disclosure of
deceptively manipulated media often
referred to as fraudulent deep fakes
without disclosure the use of fraudulent
deep fakes of a candidate or party would
be prohibited within 90 days of an
election the limited scope time frame
exists as one of several ways this bill
bends over back to amarate any First
Amendment
concerns the disclosure must appear or
be heard easily by the average viewer or
listener for a video the disclosure must
be present for the duration of the video
for an audio recording the disclosure
must be at the beginning and end of the
audio as well as interspersed within any
audio greater than 2 minutes in
length this bill allows a candidate to
take action if they are depicted in an
undisclosed deep fake the candidate May
seek injunctive relief to stop the
distribution of the deceptive deep fake
as well as bring in action for damages
against the sponsor there are a number
of First Amendment safe harbors baked
into this bill that provide exemptions
for news broadcasts Publications radio
and TV stations that make a reasonable
effort to prevent spreading deep fakes
as well as an exemption for obvious
satire or parody the aim of this bill is
to hold the sponsor of the fraudulent
deep fake accountable not good faith
Distributors HB 1596 is necessary
bipartisan Common Sense legislation that
takes a step forward to deal with the
reality of a rapidly advancing
technology capable of disrupting our
democracy and deceptively sowing
distrust voters deserve better than
deception and dirty tricks I hope
Granite State voters can count on this
committee to support HB 1596 with a
strong OTP recommendation thank you and
I'm happy to take questions questions
from the
committee represent
wey um so
on uh the first page of the bill um on
line 19 it's it talks about state and
local ballot
so are you just limiting that
to to state and local candidates and and
um or or would it apply to Federal uh
advertisement as well that uses deep
deceptive and fraudulent deep
fakes I the purpose of this bill is to
stay within the scope of the state um I
would not want to overstep the federal
level um to the extent that it could be
applied to the federal with a law in the
state then I would like that to be done
but there are federal um bills in the
works to address this at the federal
level and we may see them in the coming
year but this is a step forward um for
our state at the state
level
followup and um likewise on the same
page is there any reason for the 90 days
uh prior to an election um I know that's
probably a campaign cycle but is there
any reason why
you know we wouldn't anticipate that
people would at you know day 100 to 90
flood the market as it will were to
using such things why why the 90 days
and why not longer thank you um it is
limited in scope U Limited in time frame
to address First Amendment concerns
there have previously been bills in
other states that made it um a ban or
prohibited it year round and that face
those have faced challenges uh Court
challenges First Amendment concerns so
to keep it limited in scope IT addresses
um First Amendment concerns and make
sure that it's not violating those First
Amendment rights further questions from
the committee representative quae thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my
question on uh page one uh line
18 uh where talks about uses uses the
phrase should have
known uh that a a message was uh
deceptive or fraudulent deep fake what's
the standard of proof for
some determining that someone should
have
known uh especially given that not all
of us are technically skilled and
determining from observation what is a
deep
or deceptive or deep fake thank
you I'm I'm going to pinch it for
representative brenon here um let's save
those questions for exec um she is a
member of the committee we're not going
to vote on this the same day we exec it
I promise you that this bill is going to
need some work so if you'll excuse me
we'll we'll we'll put that one back in
the pipe try to get some of our time
back but it's a very valid question and
I will say that I I understand that
there may be some amendments to this
bill that I'll be working on with my
co-sponsor chairman Barry to address
some concerns um there are a couple of
language concerns as well as a misn
numbering in the bill that is driving me
crazy there's a reason this one's up on
the first day I'll accept that as an
answer for the time being thank you
we're g to try to get some of our time
because we could do that for all day for
all I should have done that on the first
question to be fair um other
questions okay awesome uh thank you
representative Brennan next up is
representative
Maguire and uh we're running way behind
now um so I'm going to limit every
everybody to four
minutes and try to get some of our time
back I'll try to be half that thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for your
thoughtfulness earlier I don't think
I've experienced that in any other
committee um for the record my name is
Dan Maguire I'm a co-sponsor of this
bill um I I think it's a a very good
idea we're talking here about something
that amounts to fraud and um that's an
exception to to uh free free speech is
um things like deception and fraud um
but that doesn't mean I don't think it
can be improved and in particular I'll
mention two things one is uh what
representative weie brought up the 90
days in my opinion there's no difference
if you're committing fraud on 89 days
you're committing it at on 91 days right
I mean it doesn't make sense so to me
anyways um the second thing is if you
look at page two um that's where all the
exceptions are and in particular um
Roman 4 exceptions CD and
E this I feel sort of somewhat
uncomfortable about because I in general
I don't think if you're if if you are
committing a crime um and it should also
be a crime for somebody else it it
shouldn't matter the characteristics of
you and characteristics of the other
person right I mean the either it's
wrong or It Isn't So So this thing that
makes exceptions if you're this kind of
organization but not if you're that kind
of
organization that doesn't sit right with
me so I would either eliminate those
sections or re write them in some way
and that's all my testimony thank you Mr
chairman all right will you be taking
questions absolutely okay you questions
seeing none thank uh next up Secretary
State David scalan
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State uh in support of this bill uh I
can tell you that this is at the
Forefront uh of the minds of every
secretary of state in the country um I
think this is a great first step um it's
an issue that all of a sudden is here uh
in full strength and it's going to take
a little time I think to uh just wrap
our arms around the scope uh and the
best way to deal with it uh New
Hampshire is at the Forefront of
actually having an incident with
artificial intelligence impacting an
election in the days just prior to the
presidential primary there was a robo
call that went out with President
Biden's voice on it saying that uh
telling voters to save their vote in the
primary because it's more important uh
in the general election uh so that's a
form of voter suppression I'm happy to
report that just this afternoon I saw a
press release from the Attorney
General's office apparently they have
already caught the individual that was
responsible for that uh uh that
crime so I will stop there Mr chair be
happy to answer any questions okay
questions about the
bill all right seeing none thank you
secretary scanland next up Olivia
zinc good afternoon members of the
committee I'm Olivia zinc a voter in
Franklin and reading testimony on behalf
of public Citizen and there 4,000
members in New Hampshire um and I won't
read all of this I'm just going to
paraphrase a few sentences um it's the
rapid advancements in deep te techn deep
fake technology is very concerning in
our upcoming elections um this is a real
really major threat to our democracy and
um poses a real threat so this
legislation can help um make sure that
disclosure of these deep fake
communication it's very critical that we
have that disclosure and transparency in
our elections um House Bill
1596 includes key elements um to
mitigate the Prof uh potential harms um
and I think that you know you talked a
little bit about the 90 days but also
the fact that it does carve out
exceptions um for legitimate media
sources um and also um any kind of
satire or parody um but we do urge this
committee to um OTP or ought to pass
this bill um because of the much needed
regulation to protect voters our
election and our democracy from the
harms of deep fake and artificial
intelligence questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um last
up or last at least with the pink card
is uh Autumn rashik got
Goodwin nailed it all
right all
right uh hello my name is Autumn rashik
Goodwin I'm a voter from Manchester New
Hampshire the program coordinator with
open democracy action where a
nonpartisan nonprofit representing 6,000
voters in New Hampshire um I'm not going
to read through all of this either
because a lot of the points have already
been made um really with the speed at
with this technology is
advancing it is already possible to
completely mimic someone's voice these
Technologies work similar to neural
networks and they're able to learn
faster and faster as it goes on um they
pose a particular danger to politics and
political
figures because politicians are
constantly in the public eye how many
live stream hearings have you been a
part of how many interviews how many
public appearances this is the reality
that public figures face every
day
so I hope that the committee supports HB
1596 with a vote of all to pass okay
will you be taking questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um bur
can you grab that blue sheet for me and
I didn't look online shame on me
actually I think I did look
online I didn't I didn't all right
1596 oh man I'm so popular uh 95 online
and support seven opposed on the blue
sheet we had
Services um they spoke they spoke they
spoke we have three in favor who did not
speak who uh who signed up but did not
speak um and with that going to get some
of this we're doing it I Believe in Us
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 1596 and we're going to open
up the public hearing on House Bill 1370
which we're only now 7 minutes behind
thank you for the committee for letting
me move things along uh relative to the
durable and tamperproof containers for
preserving ballots um I don't think I've
seen
oh here he
goes there it
is what is that that's out of order
1570 representative
weary Prime sponsor of the
bill you're
recognized yes um if you would give me
just one moment all right uh thank you
Mr chair and honorable committee members
for the record my name is Robert warry I
have the privilege of serving in
Hillsboro County District
13 um the barely buic town of
Hudson
and um with regard to uh this bill there
there'll be other testimony about the
current boxes and some of their
deficiencies but um just uh to introduce
this the secure handling and storage of
the ballots post elction day is
essential for providing assurance that
ballots have been properly retained
until a the completion of any necessary
or requested
recounts B the completion of any
necessary audits or investigations and C
the completion of any state Andor
Federal requirements for this retention
of ballots and related election records
when there are cardboard boxes used for
storage they're not uh ergonomically
friendly for handling by town and City
Clerks and some of the Recycled and
reused cardboard boxes are not
sufficiently durable or
stackable a as indicated by the collapse
of stacked stored boxes as witnessed
during uh routine storage recounts and
audits so um this bill is really
proposing that uh better containers be
provided for the uh use in preserving
ballots that they would be more durable
than our current kind of cardboard boxes
and that they would also be uh in a such
a state that they could be rendered
tamper proof um with that I'll happy to
take any questions all right questions
from the
committee seeing none you're going to
get off easy okay uh next up our own
representative Claudine Burnham
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members I'm representative
Claud Burnham from straford County
District 2 um many of you may have seen
um some of um the recycled cardboard
boxes that I've carried completed
ballots to and from town or city offices
to other
facilities and even for possible hand
count uh the cardboard boxes and taping
tend to weaken or even ruin the
structure of the Box uh that are
supposed to keep completed and unused
balance secure for a period of time in a
secure
location HB 1370 provides a secure
durable and portable unit that not only
provides easy wheel
Transportation um I gave a sample of
what one could look like because this
was what was uh provided at
um um secretary Estates uh demonstration
of three machines early last year and I
found that very interesting so I had
some photos to share um of what that
would look like um so this particular
one does have wheels it has a a pullout
handle um it does have a lock
feature um can even probably use one of
those safety seals that's even used on
the machines themselves uh it's just a
suggestion certainly not the end result
but um I just wanted you to have a
little visual um and also uh this
particular feature uh this one fit into
the actual box itself of the
machine
um
so the other advantage of having
something like this is that it's
portable by a pulled handle we uh for
anybody that's been involved in
elections I have helped move these boxes
or carried these boxes it's not an easy
task and they're very heavy and as you
know um cardboard tends to um get flimsy
so um having something that's a plastic
container uh that can probably Inc case
more ballots um and not just multiple
boxes uh would be helpful as well um
it's it's uh manages as a storage unit
so they're stackable easy uh to be
stored in um a safe
location and um town and City Clerks no
longer need to lift the heavy boxes they
can wheel them around so um this
particular distributor I believe was ESS
that shared uh this container
unfortunately when I did look on their
website they don't have this product for
sale so I'm not sure where they got it I
tried looking around I'm not sure if
this one was particularly made for this
demonstration or if they're available
but I would certainly be um available to
help find out other
resources uh thank you okay can we
taking questions sure all right
questions from the
committee seeing none all right next up
was David scalin from the Secretary of
State's office he works
there thank you Mr chairman members the
committee I'm David scanlin Secretary of
State and Mr chairman I have to say
given the number of bills on this
calendar today when I first saw it I
thought you were going to be here till 8
o'clock tonight but it's very impressive
job that you've kept everything the
Train's on
time um I just wanted to give a little
information uh on this bill um and a
little history uh when I first started
working in the Secretary of State's
office probably 20 years ago actually
more than
that uh there was no uniformity to the
storage containers that ballots were put
in and I can recall uh having ballots
coming in from various towns uh for
recounts that were just all shapes sizes
conditions I remember one box in
particular that was labeled medical
waste on the
outside
and no I'm not kidding
um so you know we have made progress
since then there been an attempt to the
state provides the boxes now they are uh
fairly sturdy they're uniform inside
size they have printing on them that
that uh designates them as balloting
materials um we use red security tape on
them and uh and we do training which uh
you know gets us partway there but there
are always individuals that uh will uh
close the boxes and seal them however
they feel like they want to do it so um
I understand that you know I think
although things have progressed they
they certainly are not perfect um when
this bill came up you know I I thought
about this a little bit and actually
went to the local Lowe's store and took
a look at the totes that they have uh in
their aisles and there are some pretty
rugged plastic containers out there that
um you know are the right size I mean
they're not on Wheels but but they are
of a size that it would be an easy
weight for somebody to handle somewhat
similar to the size of the boxes that we
use uh for ballots they have hard
plastic Lids on them that are flat so
they're stackable and they have holes
that go through them so that locks or uh
wire seals numbered seals could be
placed on them so something like that
would fit the bill you know a container
that might hold 1,500 ballots would cost
uh on the Shelf retail was about $17 so
I'm sure if we put that out to bid uh
ordered in bulk that that price could
come down
substantially and then in terms of how
many we would need uh you know for for
general election
uh we probably need a th000 for a state
primary
500 for a presidential primary another
500 so probably a couple thousand boxes
containers and then containers for
absentee balloting materials the you
know the envelopes the affidavit
envelopes things like that and then
having a you know an inventory of extras
you know we'll probably be looking at
about 4,000 of those
um I would prefer not to be in the
inventory management of those boxes so
what you know what I would suggest is
that they get issued to the cities and
the towns in adequate num so that they
would have enough on hand and then every
time we have an election send the
ballots to the towns in the boxes that
we use now which certainly hold up for
that purpose uh have the local election
officials count the ballots which
they're required to do in statute and
then they can put them in those uh those
totes when that job is done I think
something like that would work the um
the only additional thing that I wanted
to point out was that this uh bill would
also apply to local elections as it's
currently written which means uh towns
schools and uh Village districts and the
reason I come to that conclusion is in
chapter RC 669 colon 25 which talks
about the conduct of Elections for the
local level uh they say that you know
for the purposes of a local
election uh the the
uh the chapters 658 and 659 also apply
to town election so by passing a
provision in chapter 659 it's also going
to apply to local elections and I'd be
happy to answer any questions okay
questions from the
committee represent
Hammer thank you for taking my question
I like the idea of the plastic boxes but
wouldn't we have to seal them with the
red tape and wouldn't that all be left
on there Gunk up and they look off old
trashy eventually I I think with the
plastic totes you could eliminate the
red tape uh and the reason for that is
there is no
alternative access so on a cardboard box
there's two there's two ways that you
can enter it so the tape seals both of
those but in a tote it's it's just going
in from the top and once the cover is on
there and it has a a numbered wire seal
placed on it and a padlock it would
still require the seal that all of the
election officials
has to sign going over it but it would
pretty much eliminate the need for red
tape eliminating red tape in election
law I knew what a day I just let's go
home now representative Howard thank you
so much and thank you for taking my
question uh so in the bill the effective
date says that the ACT will take effect
60 days after uh passage uh are we are
you going to be able to provide uh these
these uh reusable transportable boxes uh
in time for the next
election I think it's I think that's
doable provided the money's there and um
you know if these are if they were you
know if we need 4,000 and let's say
they're $10 a piece that's
$40,000 right thank
you representative P O'Brien thank you I
just want to State I was going to make a
havam money joke there and I chose not
to I just want to put it on the record I
was going to make the joke and decided
not
to so the wire seal would be similar to
what they put on the electronic ballot
counting machines when those are tested
is that what you're talking about it
would be similar to that yeah I mean
obviously we would want something that
is as rugged as it could be so that you
know when they're handled the Seal's not
going to
break would the would it be a problem if
those
were um if they were taken out of
commission so to speak in a community
when there's a recount done and those
boxes go up to the state level and that
means maybe there'd be another election
coming down the pike and then the
community wouldn't have them would you
just have a bank of them at at the state
archives or something like that to then
just keep sending out to the towns I I
should have said not withstanding
recounts I mean obviously we have to
bring those ballots to conquered uh you
know in those
containers we keep we currently keep the
boxes of ballots from a recount for the
required 22 months just like they have
to do in the towns and then and then uh
after that time frame is up we destroy
them in this instance we would destroy
the ballots we would we would hold them
destroy the ballots and then send the
containers back to the towns that they
came
from okay uh represent quy thank you Mr
chairman the 4,000 estimate would that
include the need to retain ballots for
months yes the the the ballots would
have to remain in those containers for
months period right so that would that
that requirement would be
satisfied by 4,000 boxes
roughly yes the 22 months allows you to
destroy the ballots free up the
containers before the next election for
that many thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you thank you for the for the revity or
levity I should say um brevity as well
and last up is Michael
Bean Michael Bean 112 Grove Road in
Ry uh the Secretary of State this is an
easy one I think that we all can Embrace
Secretary of State ballot law commission
everyone seems to recognize the
importance of maintaining the Integrity
uh we actually have sealed ballot boxes
chain of custody and storage log as an
RSA
requirement uh there's a copy of copy of
the
document here unfortunately U during our
uh recounts they were not all completed
but the the importance of the log should
easily be recognized and the ballots
have to be stored from the night of the
election to uh date of Destruction which
has pre previously been addressed but
this this one I think is rather mundane
and that you're not um we're not
impacting anybody's right to vote we're
not there's nothing threatening about
this particular Bill and all we're doing
is trying to maintain the uh integrity
of the actual ballots themselves so I
would I would I would think it would be
something readily uh embraceable if you
will um we had this type of situation
during our recount our box our towns
that we did the recount for had never
experienced another recount in that in
that season in that election Series so
the boxes were being seen for the first
time from the town to the to the uh
building for the recount and we had
pictures like this where the boxes are
opened the tape says void um we have
labels peeled
back as you'll see here with the labels
pulled right off the boxes so the system
that we currently have is is is not
great I am fully in favor of using
sealable uh uh uh sealed with a Ys seal
containers to Main maintain that
Integrity we're supposed to have um
absentee ballot materials in a blue box
ballots in a red box those would have to
be that that distinction uh would have
to still be made but that was violated
um over and over again throughout the
analysis that we did for the recount and
um we have a I have a current situation
as I told you right now I have I've
written to the Secretary of State
Attorney General's office in my town uh
requesting an investigation for the
January 23rd those ballots must maintain
their integrity until that investigation
gets closed out um we had U
undervotes on a on a vote for one we had
many many undervotes no rationale for it
it was later corrected and uh without an
explanation so consequently the machine
count was wrong and it got modified
later I I I can't speculate why that's
why we're asking for the investigation
the Box the ballots should be uh they
should maintain their integrity until
all of those investigations are
completed so
uh I don't I don't think there's
anything threatening about this to uh as
I as I previously stated jeopardizing
somebody's right to vote it just
maintains the Integrity of the election
that took place and I would ask you all
to support it thank you okay will you be
taking questions from the
committee we didn't answer that question
I'm going say no um thank you um all
right we had one two people signed up in
person who did not speak uh both signed
up in favor of the bill online it was 11
support to opposed uh with that having
no one else signed up to speak I'm going
to close the Committee hearing on House
Bill 1370 the committee will stand in
recess until 3
p.m.
okay it's
3:00 uh going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1364 relative to
intimidation of election officers
improper influence over the electoral
process and tampering with electronic
ballot Counting devices um I need a pink
card from you at some point no you don't
need it now represent if you talk about
the right bill I'll I'll I won't need
the pink card that's a joke I'm willing
to bet Mr chair that um the pink card I
handed in earlier on the other bill has
this bill number on it it would if I
hadn't had corrected the pink card for
you oh okay very well um thank you uh Mr
chair and thank you members of the
committee once again and I know you just
heard this so my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 new market
Market in new Fields I have before you
today HB 1364 correct Bill and I'm going
I already told you a little bit about it
I think but um the bill ads needed
protection a stronger language for
election worker protections as well as
stronger language to prevent tampering
with the electoral
process um so a little bit on the
background uh onethird of our election
workers across the country uh left their
positions by by 2022 the 2022 election
cycle because of increased intimidation
of election workers um one out of five
additionally plan to leave by the 2024
election in some states as many as half
of all election workers have quit their
jobs um and many citing um increased
intimidation as a main cause 79% of
election workers across the country
believe that stronger protections are
needed to allow them to do their job
properly and safely I don't have I don't
think anyone has actual numbers for the
number of election workers in this state
that have left but we have seen a sharp
rise in in election workers quitting
their positions and the need for foam
Banks to recruit new election workers I
do know in addition that there have been
and this kind of may seem like it's two
different sides but it's it's two sides
of the same coin because anybody who
really cares about the electoral process
cares both about protecting people who
are in most cases volunteering to make
sure our elections work but also care
about making sure those people do their
correct job and don't tamper or
influence election results um and so on
the other side of that we've seen a few
examples across the country and one here
at home of uh of both election workers
being intimidated but also election
workers themselves tampering with um
with the process here in in New
Hampshire um there was a situation where
an election worker in Raymond who was
trying to um fix a machine was
physically
assaulted um also across the country uh
there have been although not actually in
New Hampshire but the idea that um that
election workers might have been
tampering with ballots became an issue
in New Hampshire a couple years ago and
it turned out that it was just as you
know um a fold in the ballots but AC
Ross the country it did happen that
election workers were tampering in
famously in Mesa County Colorado as well
as Coffee County Georgia where election
workers were disclosing the uh
proprietary information so that others
could hack those systems so we've seen
an increase in Need for both protecting
election workers as well as protecting
the process from perhaps election
workers who don't have the best um
intentions so I will get into the
details of the bill itself
so um first paragraph line five we did
not include the word retaliation in our
current protection language so we added
retaliation um as an action that would
not be
permitted also uh the idea of doxing
election workers and just so you know
we're we're talking about doxing here it
means um disseminating personal
information personal information does
not include name name is always fair but
um personal information is defined on
the next page on line eight meaning home
address telephone number uh photos of
your home photos of your license plates
those kinds of things that help people
access you personally um that disclosing
that as long as in back on the first
page the dissemination poses an imminent
and serious threat and the person
disseminating that information knows
that it would pose a serious threat then
that would be um
prohibited and then on the second page
uh starting with uh Roman numeral 2 um
except for the while conducting their
official duties uh election worker shall
not knowingly mutilate or erase any name
figure or word on a voter registration
list uh paragraph three A person shall
not knowing access or attempt to access
the voter registration system except for
official duties paragraph four a c or
town clerk shall not noing create permit
any person to create or disclose any
person an image of the hard drive or any
voting system component without the
express permission of Secretary of State
paragraph five A person shall not KN
only publish or cause to be published
passwords that would give people access
to hack
obviously um paragraph six uh well I
think that the rest of it just kind of
uh is the the housekeeping to make sure
that it is uh enforceable so I think all
of these are really reasonable changes
to help protect AR election workers also
protect our election systems from
election workers who don't necessarily
have um objective good results uh as
their as their motive and I guess with
that I'm happy to try to answer any
questions I will questions from the
committee representative Lane um thank
you um hearkening back to some of the
other bills we've heard today there was
a distinction between election off
officers and election officials so I
noticed in the in you know describing
the bill it talks about election
election officers but then thought I saw
election official on the last page um I
do say so do you know so our our
understanding my understanding was
official is the clerk the moderator the
supervisor the officers are the
volunteers
so are you bringing everybody under this
or are you just trying to keep it to
officials everybody should be included
in this um because we we were speaking
of election workers broadly as leaving
their roles and also even if they're a
volunteer and not necessarily elected by
the town you don't want them tampering
with the ballots just kind of plain and
simple you don't want anybody doing this
stuff um so yeah it should it should
cover everyone not you know despite my
very first uh request when I was a
freshman to be on Election law I ended
up on fish and game so I am not um privy
to the matters that you have discussed
this year in terms of the difference
between officers and officials and so if
there's an amendment that needs to clean
that language up that's fine okay
further questions from the committee
represent
Brennan thank you um I'm noticing the
effective date is January 1st 2025 and
I'm wondering if if there were to be an
amendment if you would be open to making
this effective sooner so that it would
pertain to the November 2024 election I
personally would be and would want it to
be um effective sooner I think the
strategy with going with 2025 had more
to do with making sure towns had enough
time but I don't know that towns don't
have enough time um so as long as say
the municipal Association didn't oppose
I think that it should be doable great
that thank you representative
wey thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question question um on page
two um where it says so you're amending
uh 659 42 tampering with electronic
ballot counting devices but then it
looks like paragraphs Roman numeral 2
three four and five are
not or at least some of some of the
aspects of this may not
be pertaining to the ballot counting
devices so so paragraph three uh
Statewide voter registration system so
it's it it's seems like
it's um the scope is beyond the title of
the paragraph and so I think that might
need to be amended and um followup if I
may yep um and do you think that this
would have any impact
on um is you we talked earlier today
about uh wrongful voting and voter fraud
you think this would have any impact on
a whistleblower who might have
discovered an
issue and wants to report it but but
then could
be themselves suppressed or intimidated
by oh I'm you know if if I bring this
forward I'm going to accuse you of these
of intimidating me and that sort of
thing so I'm just curious as to your
thoughts on that well to be clear
intimidation is already covered we
already prohibit intimidation threaten
of force violence or any tactical
coercion or intimidation to noing
discourages interfere so that's already
in our laws so um no I don't think it
would discourage a whistleblower so long
as the Whistleblower was not um doxing
them that's the only like real
retaliation and doxing are the only
things that are being added here so if
it's just falling under the general
category of intimidation then that's
currently the the issue the currently
the case intimidation is
prohibited okay further questions from
the committee representative
Ward thank you Mr chair thank you
representative we're taking my question
on page three on line two could you just
Define that for
me you're asking for disclosure programs
and Bug Bounty programs yeah what is
that well a bug Bounty program would be
um if somebody were offering a bounty to
kind of look at the programming and see
if there's an issue as I understand
it hack for representive qu thank you Mr
chairman thank you
representative on H page one lines 19
through
25 talks about a person being guilty of
a Class A misdemeanor if he or she
knowingly and without consent makes
publicly
available um personal information about
an election official
if the dissemination pauses an imminent
and the serious threat to the safety and
the person making the information knows
or reasonably should know of any
imminent and serious threat I have a
similar question the one I had
previously what's the standard of proof
for stating that someone should have
known
that
and I'll stay with a and if I can have a
followup I'd appreciate it so I'm I'm
thank you I'm sure that um
our friends on criminal justice would
enjoy having this conversation because
there are many different um criminal
acts where your culpability level so
just a little bit of out of Criminal
Justice there's typically four
culpability States for criminal law that
is purposefully knowingly careless
recklessly and carelessly carelessly and
recklessly and all of those depend on
basically what your mental state was
right did you intend to do it and so all
of that has to be proven in court and
prosecutors usually will Pro Ute at the
lowest level they think they can prove
but things that you may have written
online things that you have said to
people information you had that you
clearly had access to or that people
know that you saw or know that you heard
those types of things go to prove what
you were aware of and therefore what
you're mentally culpable
of thank you followup a followup and
this uh has two closely related aspects
to
it uh you define personal
information as including a person's home
address that's the part I'm particularly
interested in uh at the moment there are
two in my opinion two
important uh areas occasions where that
information is revealed publicly
routinely one has to do with in my town
at least the annual report has a list of
properties that are taxed or have uh
other information uh related to them
like uh was it concurrent use anyway we
have a you have a uh an exemption for
certain
uses all right uh that is important for
public transparency in term of everybody
in my opinion and that of others
believes that the list of those who are
taxed should be publicly available so
everybody can see for themselves that
it's being done in a fair manner a
second uh example of that I believe is
the voter roles where we've already
heard at least once today that it's
important that the voter roles which
typically include name and address at
the very least are made public in a
routine basis it's accessible to
everybody U I can think of one further
related example where there are some
entities that uh create their their own
list of Voters with additional
information additional data fields
they've generated themselves and it can
include information such as phone
numbers and uh mobile phones I've seen
such list
routinely so uh I don't see how
practical it is or even how desirable it
would be to exclude certain voters from
the voter roles publicly available voter
roles or certain tax certain Property
Owners from the list of property owners
so that seems to me to conflict with
your the statement in your bill so how
would you resolve that for me sure thank
you you so the the two the third example
you gave is a privately created list and
we can't really prevent people from
creating lists privately but I want to
the first thing I need to address is
that nothing in this prevents or makes
secret the name right you they can
always disclose the name we should know
the names of the election workers with
the other two examples you gave property
tax maps which obviously you know the
home address because it's the property
tax and also the voter role which you
have to know the address because you
have to know whether or not they're
qualified to vote both of those require
inherently in the definition of those
lists require the address so we already
we're already saying the name is fine
the question is is there any reason we
need to know the address of election
workers if you're not trying to hurt
them or intimidate them or retaliate
against them there's I can't think of a
reason why you'd have to know the home
address of an election worker separately
I didn't I kind of skipped over and in
my introduction but the 1B here right
afterwards is it's up really up to the
election worker the election worker is
the one that submits a request saying
that they don't want their home address
to be public so it's not automatic that
it's not public it's the election worker
can choose that protection to allow for
their home address to be um private
information um and again it's it's not
name it's just home address license
plate pictures things like
that okay qu further question on the
committee seeing none thank you
representative Reed uh next up Olivia
zinc good afternoon um Olivia zinc
executive director with open democracy a
nonpartisan organization um I think that
it's really important to look at this um
from an intimidation perspective of um
the voter the woman that the woman who
voted in in Raymond at the last town
meeting whose
ballot um jammed and instead of having a
reasonable conversation with the
moderator they assaulted them they
punched them in the face right they were
arrested they were charged this is this
is what we're seeing at elections um
maybe it's just Raymond maybe there's
some other towns you may have heard of
these examples where um election workers
are being physically harmed I have been
in in polling places where moderators
have been yelled at because people were
registered the wrong party and they
didn't realize that right we have
seen um people the I think just the tone
and rhetoric right now is really high
and and I think that many people are not
wanting to be pole workers because
they're afraid of intimidation and this
would just put some Protections in um to
ensure that there is um additional
protections for these charges and and
again the person that was assaulted in
Raymond were charged and was elevated
because it was a civil servant um but I
think it's it's important that we look
at these um just this past November um
in Washington Oregon California Nevada
Georgia envelopes of white powdered were
sent to home addresses of election
workers it was fentol in four cases um
this is what we see when election
workers um we mean doxing where their
name is published and you tell people to
do bad things and I think the Windam
toown clerk may have uh had some of that
after the 2020 election and so I think
it's important that we put these
protections um on our election workers
to ensure that
um uh we are
are really addressing the retoric and um
making sure that we're protecting uh the
civil servants that are doing the work
of of executing elections every day and
I I remember one committee meeting where
somebody threatened and intimidated you
all as committee members right so you
you've all witnessed that too
um I I'm I I I I know that they sort of
uh representative Kathleen pruto mbri
and I remember they they kind
of yeah we're looking at you yeah when
they said that and it was I was I was in
the back of the room saying this is not
appropriate behavior in a Committee
hearing um for people to intimidate the
committee so I I we know that this
Behavior exists and I think it's
important for us to um stay safe um and
so I hope you will consider this
bill okay questions from the committee
representative B Bay I saw I saw first I
saw first brother I I do I you know it's
the only time I go left first
so thank you Mr care person um so you're
talk this this bill is to protect
election um workers from I guess uh
disgruntled voters and uh does that
include voters who are
also um
candidates this scrun candidates I mean
I think I should ask the sponsor but um
does this discover
that I I I um I'm just going to say that
in the voter confidence commission
report um there was protections for
election workers and for voters so it
went both ways that we should have civil
discourse at the polls um and I think
that uh if you look back at the voter
confidence report um that uh those
recommendations were in
there okay now representative wood thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question it seems like everything that's
being addressed in this bill is already
against the law or easily covered by
what we already have in place um can you
show me a something that this is doing
that current law isn't doing I I think
you're right that there are criminals I
mean if you punch somebody in the face
there that's illegal um but I but I
think it does add a
retaliation
um because if somebody thinks you've
done something wrong that retaliation is
added but the threaten the the um
threatening is already in there yeah I
that a question followup please uh we'll
see if anybody else wants to go first
and then yes all right nobody else wants
to go so you're out so H um I sure
you've been in a voting environment as a
voter I can say it goes both ways uh the
um level of intimidation goes both ways
and there's a lot of energy in there
someone wears a political shirt uh the
way they handle that person they could
handle better in my opinion so all I'm
saying is it almost seems like we're
we're forming this special class of
servants and we're all subject as you
mentioned we're all subject to it uh
this is part of the job unfortunately
and the state running a State and State
office isn't that much different than
running in a town office when you have
to deal with the your the public the
constituent so I just think that this
this you know it's a it's a interesting
bill but I I think it's already covered
why why why why add more another layer
to it that's my question sorry for the
uh no I I think you're you're right that
there are some statutory protections um
I think this just elevates some of them
knowing how important election workers
are but I think you're right I have I
have been in the polling place I have
served as an election worker for the
last I don't know nine years and and I
think I remember nine years ago not
seeing the level of intensity that we
have people were much more polite to
each other it was a celebration people
were working together um and then you
saw some more intensity grow and and
you're right you know the voter in
exiter who took off their shirt and
voted with topless like these things
happen but you know people don't want to
remove a clothing because they think
they have a First Amendment right to
wear it but but there are we are trying
to keep the polling place sort of free
of that kind of
hostility representative BR thank you um
do election officials have a
responsibility in their role to inform a
voter if they are wearing um
electioneering hats buttons shirts don't
they have a responsibility to let that
voter know and then if that voter
responds in a way that might be
threatening or retaliating for that
election official doing their
job wouldn't this bill kind of address
that type of
situation it could and I think that when
we uh I think the secretary of state did
trainings on deescalate Conflict at the
polling place for the first time uh in
the leadup to the
2022 um elections so I I think when you
we think about how um we're training
election workers to deescalate that
conflict I think it's it's important for
us to remember you
know to me if my ballot ever got jammed
in a machine you know I would understand
that you know there's other Solutions
than punching the moderator in the face
but some people's level of anger and
hate are are up there and and we see
these activities happening and I think
this addresses that further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
so much a last up is Dan
Healey uh can you grab that blue sheet
hi uh Dan Hy Nash city clerk uh
representing New Hampshire City and town
clerks Association uh so the only thing
um I'm up here really to discuss is uh
Section 8 where it says the designated
election official shall keep all
components of a voting system in a
location where entry is controlled by
the use of a key card access or other
SIM
similar automatic entry logging system
Ian shall ensure that the log created by
the system is maintained as an election
record for 25 months following the date
of any entry So currently in nationville
we have a uh locked Vault it's not key
card and that's where our um voting
systems are stored uh the tabulators so
we do a combination to get in there it's
only city clerk staff that have access
it's locked up at the end of the day it
is open during the day when staff is
present in um monitoring that location
we could move the devices to another
location that you know we don't go into
as frequently it wouldn't be a key card
access I see the key card um component
being an issue for a lot of
municipalities to to have that um in
addition the uh tabulators have a um
activity log book and it states uh at
the front of it which members of the
clerk's office have access to these bags
so if we have to keep track of every
time we go in and out of our vault it's
the list is going to be huge um so this
uh
section8 uh I'd like to see it changed
to maybe the designated election
official shall keep all components of
voting system in a location where entry
is controlled by use of a key card
access or lock and I'm not sure on
making a record every time someone goes
into that locked area uh you have to
create then a separate spot for these um
voting systems because we're in and out
of rev Vault all day
long okay questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you um
would removing that section entirely
because there are already regulations
and statutes for the storage of voting
systems and ballots and all of that
would remove removing that section um be
better for the clerk's Association
removing the section would would would
work for us thank you further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
last up is natch
grce thank you Mr chair and H Grace for
the municipal Association we do support
the bill with Amendment um I believe
that clerk Healey outlined uh our our
major concern uh regarding the key card
entry want to make make sure that works
with everyone I'm more than happy to
work with the uh Prime sponsor and any
members of the Committees on an
amendment to make sure that this this
bill would function well for everyone
I'm happy to take any questions
questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you if the
in an amendment um the effective date
was changed to sooner like something
like August 1st rather than June 1 2025
so that this bill would be in effect for
the um Prim the state Primary in
September and the general election in
November 2024 would that cause any harm
to
municipalities I don't believe so thank
you further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um there's no one
else signed up to speak uh there was no
one on the blue sheet um and there was
96 online and four opposed with that
we're going to close the um public
hearing on House Bill
1364 that concludes cludes our public
hearings for the day congratulations we
made it um we're going to do two things
here real fast I'm going to open up the
executive session um on House Bill
1577 I'm going to immediately recess it
until next Tuesday the sponsors are
bringing forward an amendment they would
like time to work on it it is an early
Bill we will be voting it on Tuesday no
exceptions it's due out by the 15th so
we are voting for it on the we are
voting on it
on the 12th what you vote for or against
it is your business uh and then we are
going to recess for 10 minutes while we
caucus so be back here at
3:40 um a representative Lane if you
want to use my office you're more than
welcome uh the Republicans will be in
room
leave my crap in here
then
okay uh we going to open up yeah no
we're not going to call for the now uh
we're going to open up up the executive
session on House Bill
1426 FN uh since we know which way this
is going to go representative B you're
recognized for a motion I move itl on
1426 okay I'm not second yes I did I
knew you were
not parliamentary well let's let's
finish is there a second to the
motion representative anenberg uh
representative uh Osborne seconds I
believe thank you now you have
Pi yes it's
it's yeah no it's a pi it's a
parliamentary okay it actually is uh
assuming if it goes the way you said
then we can I can make an amendment
correct move to the amendment thank you
yes yes you can just
y um okay um all right is there
discussion on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate yes I like to make I mean I
made the motion itl reason being is one
of the problems that I see this
causing is if for example the bill says
that the redistricting has it done by
the legislature which is
fine uh does not listen to the
commission which it can it gives the
governor which another excuse to veto a
bill veto the bill and I have a problem
with the governor even having and say
with the redistricting and I think that
needs to be fixed so I think we need to
other things that need to be fixed and
we have 10 years to do it is not this
way not this way is let's you know fix
the county
system uh get the governor out of it but
the redistricting commission like I said
on a floor speech some years ago in
charge so in the the 16 years that I've
been in the legislature I probably eight
of those years has been the opposite so
I mean we go back and forth all the time
so and and in the senate in the
executive Council in the governor so you
know so I don't see a problem with our
current
redistricting thank you further uh
further comments on the bill hearing
none the clerk will call the role on the
emotion of inexpedient to
legislate representative B
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua
yes um sounds like there's some
breathing into mics going
on
breathing not that I mind the sound of
breathing but just just saying um
representative
Ankerberg
yes representative Burnham
yes representative wary
yes representative wood
yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane
no representative Ward
no representative HR no representative
Hamlet
no representative uh Grody
no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no Representative
rter no uh chairman Barry chair votes
yes with that the motion of in speech to
legislate fails 1010 is there another
motion that we'd like to make
representative Lane you recognized um I
would like to move to adopt an amendment
to um HB uh
1426 I passed out the amendment it's an
amendment
d513 it makes two technical changes uh
did
you I've got I've got a few does
everybody got some more you gave it out
this morning no I gave it to Ross before
you caucused he
said he he asked
me okay okay sorry for the
confusion
so you're in the middle of making a
motion I made the motion all right is
there a
second I'll second representative Hamlet
second we are now on discussion of
amendment
d513 H um to House Bill 1426 FN is there
discussion on the amendment
representative Lane is recognized um
thank you um so this makes two changes
that were requested during um the
testimony and were brought to my attent
attention is um U basically typos the
first one on page um on on line six
where the word zero is was one before it
was indic so basically it has to do in a
year ending in zero and rather than a
year ending in one because it didn't
make sense The Way It Was Written and
then the par the uh last clause on line
14 provided that such subsequent map
shall be adopted pursuant to the
procedur set forth in this chapter was
added because someone asked me if it was
clear that if we have to start over that
it's under this particular statute and I
said yes that's the intent so that's why
I added that language okay I can take
any questions my understanding
representative Lane is this is purely
housekeeping correct for that's the
intent yes okay so it is my intention to
vote in favor of this amendment even
though I just voted against the bill I
don't want to establish in this
committee the president of voting down
good faith housekeeping amendments even
when we happen to disagree so I will be
voting yes for the
amendment yes any other further
discussion hearing none the clerk will
call the role on Amendment 202 24-
0513 representative Bo no representative
pom
O'Brien I know I'm breathing um no just
because it okay just
no Representative quae no representative
Ankerberg no Representative buram no
representative
wary yes representative wood
no representative Osbourne No
Representative
kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Grody yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Rapter yes uh chairman Barry chair votes
yes with that the amendment carries 12
to8 um the we are now on an ought to
pass as amended motion on the bill as
amended is there discussion on the bill
as
amended representative Lane you
recognized so I I apologize folks but
since I missed the hearing I just wanted
to address some of the questions that
did come up and I mostly I think that
this is a way to make
our our system more transparent and more
fair and I think uh representative mure
had indicated none of us knows who's
going control control this in 2030 so
the idea is to make it as Fair as we can
and as transparent as we can I looked at
a bunch of different states um and
Colorado seemed to have although a
rather complicated way of doing it it
was the best way and it's worked um and
I think representative bone brought up a
really great point about how do you find
an independent uh voter and the same
question was asked in Colorado but
somehow they managed to find them and uh
it did even out so that it wasn't just
Democrats and just Republicans it was
Independence and it keeps you from
getting a um a deadlock and I know that
the question about the New Hampshire
Constitution states that the legislature
shall make the apportionment of
Representatives or redistrict but the
Constitution does not say how the
legislature is to make the abortion and
what process it has to follow so in this
bill the legislature participates in the
redistricting process
um and sets up a new process and is
overseeing it so with that um I would
just like to thank everybody um for
indulging me thank you further uh
discussion on the
bill all right I guess I'll close so um
going to be voting against this uh for a
multitude of reasons um I've brought an
article in from January 29th 2024 of
this year from decision desk uh
regarding Michigan's independent Rising
commission so decision desk by the way
in case you guys know that's not some
like right leaning you know Breitbart
blog that's they just they're election
nerds right they just look at numbers so
titled did Michigan's redistricting
process reduce black turnout they argue
yes uh but there's some things in here
that I think are very interesting so
after Michigan's independent reging
commission for the first time in 68
years Detroit will not have a single
black Congressman for the first time in
68 years uh majority minority District
in Michigan went from five in the Senate
10 in the house to five in the house
period period period so even when you
get to something that's independent
redistricting right it's not always kind
of what you want to get to the problem
is is when you try to live in the
fantasy land of removing politics from
this process you get to something you
basically deny what it is it is an
inherently political process I promise
you had Michigan
uh elected officials been involved you
wouldn't have gotten to a five majority
minority district in Michigan you
wouldn't and I I can virtually guarantee
you you'd probably have at least one
black person representing Detroit in
Congress so it doesn't always get you
where you want to go um I was thinking
about this last night there's actually
very few of us on the committee that
were involved intimately in the
registering process last year
representative Lane was one of them um
but that I actually think are we the
only two on the committee I think we
were um and there were some there were
things said during there that I you know
you have to be quiet because that
they're bringing things to court you
know they're going to sue um but I kind
of wanted to address some things because
this is my uh this is my let's call it
my redistricting airing of
grievances um so my friends at the ACLU
um used to be one of the most you know
Center um let's call it I don't want to
say ideological but um principle driven
organizations right these are the the
people that took on the horrible task of
representing the clan when they wanted
to March right they sue in Arkansas they
sue in South Carolina they sue in South
Carolina but they don't Sue in Illinois
they don't Sue over Jerry mandering in
Illinois and I've brought copies of
Illinois's congressional district if
you'd like to look at them um I think
that they would meet what you would call
the definition of Jerry mandering so
it's so curious to me how the
nonpartisan ACLU just manages to
overlook um manages to overlook illin
Illinois manages to overlook Illinois
but yet yet manages to go to Republican
states um our friends at America votes
the nonpartisan group they are funded by
the Democrat legislative Campaign
Committee and the DNC as a whole so like
love them I think I'm I'm working with
them on the U CA bill um but they're
hardly
nonpartisan right uh lastly and this one
hurt me the most because my grandmother
was a member of the League of Women
Voters the League of Women Voters New
Hampshire ran a Facebook ad redirecting
voters not women voters but student
voters redirecting student voters to the
Grafton County Democrats uh YouTube
page so it's hard to like take these
things seriously when you have groups
that are not always kind of presenting
what they are who they say they are um
lastly let's talk about my friends the
mapathon the open democracy action
subgroup right so they came here and
they testified and they said that the
least gerrymandered map currently in
existence is the new current New
Hampshire uh Congressional map that is
arguably the most Jerry Mander map
that's currently existed and in fact its
entire purpose when it was drawn
dividing Manchester nashille was
actually to suppress the Catholic vote
we just haven't changed it since then um
don't believe me look it up it's all
there it's all there so that map has
over the last 10 years produced One Cong
one Republican Congressman one time so
it has a 5% win rate for Republicans yet
46% of the vote has gone
to Republicans so 46% of the voters have
been represented 5% of the time um hard
to take that seriously when you say that
that's the least Jerry maned map they
also happen to be suing over the State
House map once again they said the
Congressional map is the least Jerry
maned map the State House map so they
they use the standard right of oh look
at the Statewide vote right look at the
Statewide vote the State House map was
the one that got closest to the
Statewide vote it was off by like half a
percent and yet that's the one they're
suing over and are they suing to move
one Ward and Keen over to make the whole
map work no they're suing throughout the
whole map they're s throughout the whole
map so they're not in my opinion I I
it's hard for me to view them as honest
brokers in this conversation um you know
when we did the registrating probably
the the smartest thing that ever came
out of my mouth was this is a thankless
process it's an ugly process um and you
can do one of two things you can make a
map that looks good or you can make a
map that actually functions um to try
and separ seate this process from the
legislator is to further remove it from
the voters not to further empower the
voters this bill would further Empower
judges not further Empower people um I I
understand that this is the way we draw
district is not popular it is not um it
is not always definitely not pretty I
can assure you that um but to try and
act like it's not political just denies
what it is so I will be voting against
this I'll be voting against future
efforts of this because I truly believe
in my heart of hearts um and I would say
this if I was in the minority um that
this is a process that the farther it
gets away from the legislator the more
concocted and actually the more distance
from actually being representative it
will be so with that those are my cing
arguments I brought everything if you'd
like to see it um and that is my um
Festivus on
redistricting all right the clerk will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass do
amended feel like we need droppable mics
cuz that could picture you dropping a
mic after that
one um representative B
no representative Pome O'Brien no
Representative quae no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
representative weary no representative
wood no representative Osborne nope
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative gr yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes no
with that the motion of ought to pass as
amended fails the bill will be reported
out of committee as no recommendation uh
per the instructions of the speaker
reports are due by the end of the day so
we have till today today today so uh
representative quaale do you believe you
could do the report for itl or do you
want me I can't speak against the
committee so technically well you want
to write it okay a representative bone
will take itl and I assume
representative Lane will take otpa right
ready in the report okay and with that
uh we see um so here's what's what going
to close the executive session on House
Bill 1426 couple of housekeeping things
I'm going to go and make nice with
representative Lane after my bombshell
um we're going to work on the scheduling
for next week um any votes that we take
on Thursday will be votes that
representative Lane myself and
representative bone believe will be 180
19020 like we saw on Thursday um so no
votes on Thursday that we don't believe
will all be on the same page on um and
with that um I'll see you guys on
Thursday